à à
ừ ừ
anh alo alo chào các bạn alo một người
nghe thấy mình nói gì không
ừ ừ
anh alo
à
mà rồi alo nghe rõ đúng không
ừ ừ
Ừ Tự nhiên alo ghé dám Đang từ năm mấy
người còn 20 người nói chưa ạ
à à
Ừ
thôi Nam nhiều quá rồi không tốt
anh em thấy cái vụ Tab toàn bộ tất cả
sinh viên là không tốt rồi
ở
tại sao hôm nay tự nhiên lại like sớm
thế mà Bởi vì kéo mình nghĩ là cũng
trước ra là
có nhựa có có một bạn thôi Bạn nói cho
mình nghĩ ở nó cũng ảnh hưởng Đó là một
bạn bảo là
Em
có phải cái chuyện nó hơi Bên Lề một tí
nên là mình nên tập trung vào Dậy thôi
chỉ nói những chuyện bên lề
nhau mà thực tế là mình mình nghĩ thì
Anh nhớ là học online Dạo này và nó có
cái hay đó điểm là việc là
U22 cho bạn thấy mình đã mình tiện việc
thì đỡ phải đến trường dạy offline cho
các bạn được nó chẳng hạn thế cũng như
là gì
cho mình kiểu hoàn toàn thoải mái thoải
mái trong việc dậy yêu đương nhiên là
vẫn phải dạy cho nó dậy đúng không Vẫn
phải nghiêm túc những dậy mình không cần
nhà dậy được nhưng ngoài ra thì ở Nếu
sinh viên mình mình từng nói sinh viên
mình là các bạn không nên gọi mình là
thầy bởi vì sao vì mình không đốt cháy
mình thấy mình chưa đủ tư cách của một
người thầy
thì các bạn cũng không nên gọi mình ở
thấy gọi mình anh mình thích hơn Tại sao
và đặc biệt là thứ hai gọi mình hai bà
sinh viên mình gọi anh Hòa tiền bối nó
sẽ hợp lý hơn vì thực ra mình cũng không
hay làm con người gương mẫu lắm cũng có
lúc những lúc trẻ trâu những lúc cậu
mình vẫn Tuổi Trẻ trâu mà đã
và mình vẫn muốn thoải mái
Anh kéo nó gần gũi thì các bạn hơn cái
từ thầy Nó kiểu nó cứ bị sa là anh ấy Nó
kiểu bị
khi bị hẳn phân cấp rõ ràng
Ừ mình chỉ là người đi trước mình sẽ
truyền lại những cái kiến thức cũng như
là những bí quyết trong cái ngành nghề
này để giúp các bạn đi con đường dễ hơn
cũng như là đồng hành cùng các bạn
Ừ để cho các bạn kiểu có thắc mắc gì thì
hỏi Bởi vì lúc khi người thầy đặc biệt
là gần đây tự nhiên hay ô mai mình xem
mày cái video liên quan đến có các thầy
cô kiểu
tạo áp lực cho sinh viên rất nhiều sinh
viên và kéo thái độ cái bao nhiêu chặt
đôi học hãy vân vân các thứ thứ mình
thấy mình cái thầy cô đấy chỉ
chỉ làm cho người khác sọ chứ không hẳn
là làm người khác nè nề thì mới khiến
cho người khác hiểu khâm phục và kiểu
học tập được còn hơn là kiểu
Tình hình là kiểu dặn là làm người khác
sợ người ta sẽ kiểu làm mọi thứ theo
kiểu Đối phó
thế nên là mình mình thấy da mình rất
ghét những người thầy cô kiểu thế bìa
như thầy cô có thể đôi khi không hạn có
tâm nữa họ làm thì cái tội rõ hơn họ đôi
khi không hẳn đã nghĩ cho sinh viên mà
họ kiểu để tủ lạnh là họ nghĩ cho họ
nhiều hơn thì mình ở thế
Anh thành ra là kiểu họ không Có tắt mày
sinh viên đang học được hay không
à mà họ chỉ quan tâm việc là họ có dậy
dễ dàng cho họ không Vân Vân Vân Trường
mình từng đi dạy cũng hơn một điển hình
cũng có có có một vài đời cô như thế gần
như là kiểu người ta là
anh không được không xứng đáng là Thầy
mình lại nói thẳng như vậy Giống như là
người làm thuê hơn
ừ ừ
khi mình không còn dạy ở cái cá kết nữa
thì mình nghĩ dại cũng hơn nửa năm ở đâu
đầu năm nay thêm em cho lâu rồi à
Ở nhà nói chung là ở đấy do mà một chút
đi Ra mà mình Bây giờ mình sẽ livestream
sớm hơn một tí thực tế là bây giờ video
mà đền á 9 giờ sẽ làm một tiếng rưỡi
nhưng mà bây giờ mình sẽ làm cái mục lục
kia các bạn xem YouTube từ ra có cái vụ
lại chia phân chia mục lục của video thì
mình sẽ làm chia mục lục Ví dụ ở nửa
tiếng đầu thì đôi khi là sẽ tâm sự những
cái trải nghiệm hay ạ
ở thẻ sao phải nói là kiểu những Nói
chung ở chia sẻ
tuổi hồng chứ tâm sự tuổi hồng đúng
không để cho các bạn thấy thấy cái gì
em thấy mình là một đại diện
11021 đại diện nó chút và một cái gì đó
một mẫu điển hình của dân công nghệ
thông tin lập trình thì nó sẽ như thế
nào để các bạn cảm thấy ạ
ở góc nhìn còn mà dân công nghệ cũng như
nhà của một người đã đi làm rồi đúng
không Thì họ sẽ nghĩ gì họ sẽ làm như
thế nào các bạn cảm thấy có thích điều
thế không thích tiếp xúc người đấy hay
là thật chứ thích đậu muốn trở thành một
người cũng na ná Thế cậu có cuộc sống
như thế không đúng không phải ý mình là
như thế nghĩa là mình đôi khi mình chia
sẻ thế chia sẻ cuộc sống mình không phải
là hắn Chị ở để cho vọng khoe hai cái gì
cả mà cốt là để cho các bạn thấy là
mình có muốn kiểu như thế không
thì mình sẽ không dùng tấm gương thì ra
là tấm gương của mình thì sinh viên mình
mà đang xem cái bộ loài chim này sẽ thấy
nó không phải là tấm gương sáng gì cả
và kiều mình chỉ sau cực mình đi dạy
tiền mình dậy vẫn rất là từ từ nha Cái
thơ khuẩn ra từ thế nhưng mà khi mình
trẻ trâu mình có thể chửi rõ nó đứng
nhưng không phải trên lớp mà lúc đi chơi
hay các hơn thế nên là
Ừ mình cũng không hẳn là một kiểu người
mà cậu
có một cái tấm gương sáng
có ai con người mà Ngọc thầy cô cho cái
bản chất của những người bình thường
thôi Chẳng qua là những lúc cần nghiêm
túc mọi thứ thì mình cần nghiêm túc đúng
không yên
Ừ thì nó mới tạo một sự gần gũi đúng
không Đúng rồi cái hướng của mình là như
thế nghĩa là hướng của mình lại gần gũi
làm cho sinh viên cảm thấy là ông này
giống như kiểu Ông anh mình mà giống ý
tưởng ông bạn mình mà hẳn các bạn đã
biết rồi học tại Học thầy không tày học
bạn đúng không Nghĩa là kiểu các bạn sẽ
có động lực hơn sẽ nghị không nghĩ là
ông ấy một người một cao siêu mình sẽ
không Ở Với Tới Vì sẽ không bao giờ được
như anh ấy hai cái gì đấy Không chỉ là
người đi trước mình và giờ họ chia sẻ
lại bí quyết để mình có thể đi con đường
mà dễ hơn dễ hơn Ở Non nhé bởi vì mình
đi ngựa mình Mình biết những con đường
là khó con đường nó dễ rồi đúng không
Thì mình sẽ chỉ còn bạn con đường Ông ổn
hơn tí đúng không
E bằng phẳng hơn một chút cái kiểu thế
để các bạn sẽ đi tiến xa hơn mình chứ
không phải chỉ mỗi dừng lại mỗi được
chia sẻ kiến thức hay các thứ Bởi vì các
thầy cô ở trên lớp túi khi ạ là tạo cho
các bạn một cái sự xa lánh nữa là kẹo
cậu Dạo Các bạn thấy khó gần gũi cũng
như khó thắc mắc đưa ý kiến đúng không
rõ ràng là
khi họ thường y tạo một cái bức tường
như thế rồi đúng không các bạn nói cái
gì thì đôi khi họ dập tắt ngay
Ừ nó làm cho các bạn rất thụ động các
bạn không dám hỏi
cho nên là khi đi làm các bạn mới hỏi
lúc đấy Quá muộn Bởi vì lúc đấy thực sự
này người ta cũng đi làm giống như các
bạn thôi Thực sự như thế người ta không
được trả tiền khi mà trả lời các bạn đâu
Thế nên là người ta đôi khi có nhiều
người sẽ rất khó chịu khi các bạn họp đó
là mất chung các bạn đúng không
ừ ừ
ca nhạc chuông vào đấy những cái tâm sự
của mình mình mình muốn à Bây giờ mình
sẽ có thể là trình sớm hơn một tí sớm
anh thì không không hạt cố định thời
gian là sẽ sớm bao nhiêu lâu là chuyện
này sớm hơn một tí đẹp mà nó Tâm sự qua
rồi có thể cho chuyện các bạn để các bạn
cảm thấy gần gũi gì đó còn những bạn nào
mới thực sự muốn chỉ nơi đây để học tập
đúng không Thì mình cũng sẽ vẫn sẽ đúng
giờ 8 giờ mình sẽ bắt đầu dậy à các thứ
tư đúng không dậy thì Nhưng mỗi khi mình
rảnh chị tối đa là một tiếng thôi đúng
không có thể là hôm mấy hôm trước còn nợ
tía nó hôm nay có thể sẽ nhiều hơn
đã có những buổi nào mình sẽ bảo nó sẽ
kiến thức nó sẽ nhiều hơn và khó hơn một
tí rồi Các bạn cũng sẽ phải hiểu đúng
không Đấy nó sẽ nhiều hơn và để các bạn
hoàn toàn thì qua lấy bạn mới để học
đúng không
ở lại chỗ nhà
Ừ cái này nó là bài toán giống kiểu chi
mô mà đúng không Đó là khó mà chiều lòng
tất cả mọi người nhờ mình sẽ làm như thế
mà ai cũng thấy là kiểu một cái video
này nó có ích một phần nào đó cho các
bạn nhỉ đúng có bạn đã nói cái mà
Ừ mình định thông báo bạn đây đó là á
Mình mới
mới tạm đóng câu lạc bộ
ở bên Belt của mình nếu mà bạn nào xem
trên kênh YouTube của mình thì ạ
nhà mình có có một cái video mình quay
câu lạc bộ
Ừ anh em Asus mini mình xóa cái video
măng tô có chỉ còn mỗi cái video nói Ăn
nói lịch sự ở trên cái á
người kênh bình thôi hôm trước mình đã
bấm sờ ơi
cho mình cái video đấy là video mình
dậy giới thiệu mà câu lạc bộ mới coi bộ
Lập trình là trường mình
ở đầu tiên tại sao mình là thằng giới
thiệu và sáng tạo câu lạc bộ đương nhân
bởi vì bản chất trước đó cái trường mình
là có mỗi hai câu lạc bộ trưởng Mình
thực ra rất ý sinh viên
Y Sinh viên bởi rất ít người biết đến
nhưng mà
chỉ có mỗi hai bộ Câu lạc bộ một câu lạc
bộ Câu lạc bộ văn nghệ và một câu lạc bộ
nó có bộ tình nguyện và thực sự hai câu
lạc bộ đấy Mình thấy là chỉ hoạt động
khi mà có những cái dịp lễ nào đó thì
cần có các tiếp một vấn mẹ văn nghệ cũng
như là cần phải à
Ừ nó Vũ hậu trường hay là chạy bê vác
thì hai câu lạc bộ đấy hoạt động thành
ra là mình cảm thấy
ở các trường của mình không có một câu
lạc bộ nào nó có bộ học tập có biết
không Câu lạc bộ nào giúp các bạn gắn bó
với nhau ở đây Thế nên là mình mới tạo
ra một câu lạc bộ của bộ lập chính ở bên
trường mình để mà các bạn làm à cảm thấy
cậu tự như hôm nay hướng lên học phí thì
có muốn Ôi để mà hỏi đáp không phải học
tập mình sẽ gặp những cái bạn mà có trí
của mình để học về hỏi đúng không Đấy
các thứ
anh nói chung là mình lập câu lạc bộ đấy
lâu rồi và
ở bên đây gì phải thấy là không còn ở
trường cũng không offline có thứ nữa
thành ra là cậu vụ
áo kiểu chẳng sống nổi nữa
số lượng người tham gia hôm trước Online
đó là 4 người 4 người thì là mình cảm
thấy ở cậu trả bây giờ cái gì nó đến hồi
kết rồi mình không thể nào mà níu kéo
nữa
Vì thế nên là mình mới đóng câu lạc bộ
và
ạ Và bây giờ mình lại rảnh thứ năm thì
nên Chắc là bây giờ mình nghĩ là nếu mà
không vướng lên các thầy khác thì mình
sẽ dậy vào thứ ba năm bảy tuổi 357
Thật ra thì tốt để mà các bạn hoàn toàn
ngăn kéo
Đại học kiến thức theo kiểu liền mạch
sẽ cắt một ngày học một lần khá hợp lý à
cho mắt bé chắc mình nó lại bẻ đấy tôi
cam ít rất to đấy nhá chạy qua mình là
bé đó nói kiểu giọng mà Thì da mình
không biết được là mình nói giọng có
buồn ngủ kẹo đều đều không
à à
Ừ đúng rồi anh níu kéo mà phải dùng từ
níu kéo buổi vừa thực sự là
từ hồi đầu là rất nhiều người tham gia
xong rồi về sau càng ngày cảm xây dựng
dần mẹ mình vẫn cố hoạt động 1 tuần 2
buổi
công nghệ tuần nạn thế Kể cả bây giờ
mình không dạy ở trường nữa mình vẫn cho
câu lạc bộ hoạt động để một sự rất là
nhiều kéo đúng không ạ
Ừ nhưng mà thực sự thì
các bạn Các bạn cho người bộ thì cũng đi
làm đi thực tập hết rồi Anh thấy cũng
khó cho các bạn đấy nên là mình nghĩ ra
Ừ mình cũng phải dừng Thôi để mà mình
mình sẽ dành thời gian khác
dành thời gian đấy cho những người khác
chú trọng hơn cần hơn đấy thế nên mình
nghĩ bây giờ mình sẽ mở
lớp 1 tuần 3 buổi cho bên mình đúng
không thì ổn hơn không
lễ hội ma xó em mượn mày Xóa gần đây
cũng
Ờ Ờ mình có mình có mở cả câu lạc bộ ma
sói nữa Nhưng nhưng mà có thể gần đây
bớt sôi nổi rồi à
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói về vụ đỗ đại học
hôm trước mình có bình luận trong chính
cái bài ở ở bên vuốt ve vn vô gia với
là mình trượt cấp 3 mình Trượt đại học
Ý mình là phải vào học cao đẳng nghề
ẩm thực sự là kiểu nghe thấy cậu tâm thế
cả
chị thay cậu nó hơi nát so với nhiều
người
và hồi cấp 3 mình còn học sinh trung
bình cơ như kiểu là mình chỉ học những
cái môi mình thích thôi à
Ừ
nhưng mà bây giờ để ngồi đây tao nói
kiểu mới nói lại nghe cũng vậy là này đã
có cái gì đó đúng không các thứ thì ra
là mình vẫn cảm thấy mình với Mạnh may
mắn May mắn hơn nhiều người về việc là
mình gặp đúng thầy cô để mà hướng dẫn
mình đi con đường ổn các thứ xong rồi sự
sự nghiệp cũng ổn
Ừ cái nói hơi khoe một tí đó là kiểu
mình may thì điểm đó Kiểu mình thôi ca
từ trước mai mình phỏng vấn đều rất là
dễ bởi vì a mình toàn được sợi mời được
giới thiệu về thế nên là mình chẳng phải
qua cái phỏng vấn vào cả khi mà đi làm
Ừ đấy là một cái điểm mà mình cảm thấy
rất may
à À đấy đế về làm ngành Công nghệ thông
tin này nhá 05 nhất của mình mình đã
từng trải qua đủ có thể loại lao động
chân tay để mà để mà kiểu
xem qua là mình có hợp với cái nghề gì
Học cả vào chung là
35 nhất thì thường à Rảnh mà Đúng không
cậu đi làm kiếm tiền đi làm bắt chước
các bạn các thứ
thì năm nhất mình còn lao động đủ mọi
cái từ rồi bà này từ pha chơi dị pha chế
còn ba này sau đó Gì đó làm ở siêu thị
này chưa Chạy đi grab thôi à
Ừ nhưng mà mình cũng khuyên sinh viên
mình đó thế đó lắm nhất là các bạn chưa
Học chưa học cái môn chuyên ngành có
thời gian thì các bạn nên tham gia những
kiểu đi làm như thế để mà kiếm thêm thu
Nhật thì được à nóng ít thôi Chẳng qua
là các bạn
để có cái nhìn khác rồi Các anh người
khác để các bạn cảm thấy là ngành nào
phù hợp với Minh hoa cả các bạn thấy
nhanh đấy không phù hợp với mình thì sao
thì các bạn sẽ phải cố gắng những cái
ngành các bạn đang theo để mà các bạn
Trân trọng đồng tiền trân trọng thời
gian trước các bạn không kiểu dạng là
năm nhất thì ngồi chơi rồi 52 đi học thì
cảm thấy học khó Vãi thì các bạn lại nản
ừ ừ
à à
vợ mình có quan hệ rộng nhà đấu Nếu một
tí nha Bây giờ là mình quen biết rất
nhiều người mai mình quay biến rất nhiều
người lại ví dụ quen biết các bạn cũng
là rất nhiều người rồi đúng không đấy
nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà tính của mình đó là
cứ gặp ai mình để mình tự là mình cảm
thấy mình mình làm cho người khác có ấn
tượng với mình thì ra là họ nhớ mình hơn
mình nghĩ thế chứ về các bạn thì lớn đây
nè Ai cũng sẽ tiếp xúc rất nhiều người
trừ những người trừ những lời nhé là
em lại thay đổi ví dụ làm như vừa mình
vừa nói năm nhất của mình làm rất nhiều
nghề đấy đúng không 52 mình cũng đi làm
cá thứ mà mình đã gặp rất nhiều con
người có những người tiểu ban làm một
nghề 315 ừ thì đương nhiên là được thăng
trước đã lên lưng K vân vân vân Nhưng họ
chỉ gặp đi gặp lại những con người đấy
thì họ sẽ mối quan hệ của họ sẽ ít trừ
trừ một vài nghề không nói đến một vài
nghề chỉ đi quan hệ giao lưu không nói
gì nhưng nói là khi họ không hậu tuổi
trẻ mà họ ít thay đổi
nó giống như là mình nghỉ dạy ở đây này
mình nghỉ dậy này để mình ra ngoài ra
trạm này Đó mình không ngại thay đổi
mình nghĩa Tuổi trẻ là phải va chạm phải
khám phá các thứ đúng không
Ừ thì thế thì mới có nhiều câu chuyện để
mà gặp được nhiều người để mà có nhiều
trải nghiệm đúng không và để tạo ấn
tượng cho họ Vân Vân rồi cái kiểu kinh
nghiệm mình có nữa
Ừ chứ không lên chỗ làm đi làm lại một
chỗ một nơi các bạn hệ rất gọi vì chỗ đó
nhưng mình thấy các bạn biết mỗi chỗ đó
các bạn chỉ gặp đi gặp bạn những con
người đó đúng
Em à mình thì cứ tính mình là người
thành công đâu mình chỉ tính mình người
à
khi tổn định tạm thời ổn định bây giờ
tạm ổn định
Khi bữa em nhận dạng dữ liệu bit Mà tại
sao nó ra Chu phone à trú thôn thì mình
từng nói bit là bạn nhị phân thì đồ máy
tính hiểu nó là 10 chú phone là nó hiển
thị ra nó vẫn thế
em coi 24 tuổi mới học không
hai thí sinh năm 97 nên Chắc là bây giờ
mình 24 tuổi chắc là bằng bạn Đúng không
chị ạ
nhà
mình gần đây mình có gạch 3 bồn đứa bạn
của mình bây giờ cha 34 bận đứa bạn ấy
cũng đang ngồi xem livestream này và nó
có thể nó sẽ trả lời được câu lấy gì của
bạn mấy bạn đấy học đủ mọi ngành luôn có
bạn thì đang học bên ngành nghệ thuật bà
dọn bạn chuyền đánh đàn này bạn một bạn
bạn DJ đấy mấy giờ vậy không nổi lắm để
bây giờ trên ngàn bạn nữa bạn bên hát
rồi các thứ bạn đấy Cũng bây giờ mới bắt
đầu học đấy Nên là chắc là cũng không
hẳn đã muộn đâu
à à
ừ ừ
ở người già thì thực ra là thỉnh thoảng
mình trên già rồi nhưng mà mình vẫn còn
trẻ trâu lắm
à à
thế hả Sao tự nhiên để cực mạnh tuấn 24
tuổi này mình nói mình 24 tuổi mà hôm
nay Mạnh Tuấn Anh mới 20 thôi
à à
Ừ hôm nào bảo tôi 24 tuổi đây
cho tôi bảo tôi 24 tuổi đúng không Đấy
hiệu trưởng vừa nói đấy hiệu trưởng chỉ
có 20 tuổi thôi à
ở tuổi 20 tuổi nha à
Ừ tôi đừng bảo nữa hả cứ buổi loài chim
thì chắc chắn an thầy hiệu trưởng sẽ
ngồi kiểm tra 10 điểm danh thôi ạ
ừ ừ
à à
à
à bê của Ông ra ông ấy hỏi câu đấy à
nhà mình có nói luôn cách
Còn 10 phút nữa mà tranh thủ mẹ nghe
Mình chém gió một tí cách mình gọi một
người khác làm anh hoặc thậm chí à Nói
chung là gọi người khác Thầy Hai ạ Mình
có một người thầy người anh này một đại
ca này một người tiền bối
ở những cái người mà mình xưng hô đôi
khi không phải do tuổi của họ
cho mình
vì mình không biết các bạn như nào đối
với mình thì trên dưới vì nó không phải
phân qua mỗi chức vụ anh cũng như là
người kia sinh ra mình trước hay cái gì
đó vân vân vân cũng không phải hẳn nó Họ
hơn mình thì mình mới kiểu này trọng họ
mình để người ta
đó là bởi vì à
Ừ chắc là để cái Cách ứng nhân xử thế
của họ khiến mình đẹp
ông Nguyễn Khắc phục là mình
cách xưng hô người ta cách gì đó em
ờ ờ Ví dụ mình có Có
anh à Mình là gọi anh nữa đại ca phải
nặng Anh sinh năm 96 tự như anh ấy không
phải dân giang hồ cũng như là anh ấy
không cho dạy là hiểu hay như đánh nhau
thì gọi 2k mà Bởi vì à người đầy ý á
ngoài việc rất là giỏi người ta vẫn rất
biết cách đối nhân xử thế người ta khiến
mình rất mệt được cho là
vui tính vừa khéo cũng như là hỏi câu
nào chắc nịch cậu ấy anh ấy người nói
anh nói ít làm nhiều anh ấy Cả ngày anh
ơi chị muốn cắm đầu vào học đúng cho dân
Bách Khoa mà à
Ừ như vậy nhưng mà anh ấy rất là giỏi mà
đẹp trai nữa tao thầy cũng cũng đồng
nghiệp dậy dậy ở bên trường cũ của mình
khi hai người chưa có nhiều đâu đấy nghe
thấy có vẻ đó
em rất nhiều em theo đuổi Nhưng thực sự
là
Ừ anh để ý nghĩa kiểu dạng lá anh ấy chủ
chưa nghĩ chuyện yêu đương đi anh ấy
toàn bộ lại Bây giờ anh đang yêu tổ quốc
yêu đồng bào với anh ấy chỉ tập trung
những cái đấy thôi
anh ơi không
anh không hiểu nhiều ở bãi trường
ừ ừ
Ê mày thấy người đấy khiến mình cảm thấy
rất mệt và gọi anh ghé đại ca đã
Từ Liêm
Ừ anh đẹp trai
anh khẳng định luôn Không không phải từ
góc nhìn của một thằng con trai rồi nhận
xét nhé
Ý mình nói không tiện đăng ảnh anh đấy
lên đây thôi Các bạn nhìn qua sẽ thấy
anh đấy mặt mũi sáng sủa tượng tùm đẹp
trai có cứ nói chung à
ở mình cho anh đấy nhiều thì chẳng thấy
nhiều tiền như mấy trừ việc à anh ấy
cũng trẻ trâu hơn của mình nên là mình
mới có anh ấy là đại ca
Ừ anh trẻ châu Á
à à Không chúc lúc này đi dạy lại rất
nghiêm túc anh ấy kiểu dân Bách Khoa
kiểu sống nội tâm ít nói mà nhưng mà
khi con lúc đi chơi rồi mới nghỉ kéo hai
đứa trẻ trâu chơi với nhau thì bộc lộ
hết cái đổi trẻ trâu ra
khi
mấy người thì cứ cứ nói mấy cái chuyện
kiểu đi sai lệch tính nhỉ Rõ ràng mình
nói là nói chuyện rất là lành mạnh ừ ừ
em mình đi chơi vì anh ấy nhiều ông ăn
bất cứ đâu mà ngon
ừ ừ
36 phút à mình sẽ nói gì đây à mình sẽ
xem qua các câu hỏi hôm trước xem nó có
gì không có lớp về ai Cái này mình có
nói với anh Tuấn rồi
Ở Nhưng mà thực sự thì
ạ bây giờ cần người
chỉ cần người phụ trách những cái kênh
đầy đã bây giờ thực ra ở đang có nhiều
kinh quá mà chiều thai phụ trách thành
ra lại mở ra thì các bạn gần như chỉ vào
ngồi nói chuyện với nhau chủ yếu thôi
nhưng mà chắc là mình vẫn sẽ mở thứ thử
mở kênh đấy xem
em có web nào hay thôi mình mình cứ tặng
đến cái đoạn nào liên quan đến tâm sự cứ
thử ở đây đây
Ờ Ờ sao anh nói chậm thế
Ừ cái này là một câu cũng
à rất là mình cảm thấy là nhiều Đúng các
bạn kiểu hỏi đúng cái mà mình muốn trả
lời
thật sự như ý
ở tại sao bởi vì à mình cố tình nói chậm
bình thường ở ngoài đời mình không nói
chậm như này đâu Mình nói kiểu nhanh hơn
cũng khôn ở bản rap triển giảm nhanh hơn
Nếu như bây giờ nhé Bây giờ mình sẽ đang
nói sớm nhanh này nhưng mà đây mới tốc
độ thật của mình chưa Nhưng mà ở trên
này thì mình nói chậm Tại sao bởi vì
mình đang cố vừa nghĩ vừa nói sau cũng
cho câu chữ nó chắc chắn nhất
nghe lời nói nó a cho nhiều người nghe
mạn đúng không nên là lời nói phải có
trọng lượng và phải kiểu Trọng một tí
cũng như là ở mình muốn phù hợp cho bạn
nào mà
em nghe không anh là nghe rõ lắm thì sẽ
ngày tốt hơn
cô bạn thân mình nghe nhạc nhiều nên nó
khi mình cũng không nghe rõ người khác
nói gì nhưng là mình rất thích Cài video
nó nói từ từ tí đặc biệt khi mình đang
học mà đúng không học bảo tức cả việc là
cái chữ đấy vừa vào não vào não các bạn
thì các bạn phải từ từ các bạn mới thấm
được đấy Cái thứ nhất thứ hai là
Ừ cái này càng tốt cho các bạn nào muốn
chơi kiểu tua nhanh đấy Kiểu thế các bạn
mở Chế Độ Thực ra các bạn sẽ đi ra mình
nhé người các bạn tour lên 1,5 mình
thường iTunes để để mà sẽ lại video
nhanh của mình mà mình thấy lên 1,5 vẫn
hoàn toàn nghe được vẫn dễ nghe mà cái
việc tua như thế thì các bạn làm làm cái
làm cái não các bạn bị đánh lừa là tí ra
lại ngắm lắm các bạn thường được em ạ
Ê bà thứ ca mình định mình không Trước
mình còn nói chuyện với anh Tuấn Vụ này
mình có quen một vài người cũng dậy
nhưng mà người ấy thường hay tua tua cái
video của họ để cho video của họ trông
có vẻ rất hào lắm nhưng mà họ lại bắn
quá nhanh thành ra là kiểu mình lại phải
khi mà mình xem video ấy mình lại phải
tôi chọn lại
Ừ anh ra làm nó biến người dùng thành
vào thế trúc bị động theo kiểu là thọ
phải chủ động để mà làm
làm nó chậm lại đúng không còn khai gì
thế bây giờ các bạn tại vào biến thế chủ
động đúng không Và Các bạn thấy chậm quá
thì bọn tăng lên đúng không Thế là mình
nghĩ là đây là một cái
vì lý do mình cảm thấy nó hấp mình để
trả lời câu của bạn còn không nghỉ đi
khi tổng gọi hôm trước thời gian mình có
nhắc đến tôi đi cô Dạo này nhiều mình
không tiện nhắc tên mình không vậy cho
nó xấu cho ra đấy một cách 2 của anh để
mà một cái chỗ ai ai dậy cũng có một cái
kiểu hướng riêng ví dụ là anh ấy thích
dạy về mảng Hồi trước có nhiều người nói
là kiểu Anh ấy thì anh nhắc nhấn gái
xinh nhiều Mình thực ra mình cũng thường
anh nhắc đấy đến đấy nhưng mình ko nhận
ví dụ không nhiều và nhanh đấy cũng như
là anh ấy thường hay tua nhanh để cho
người khác cách bé một cách cơ mà mỗi
người có 10 hướng đúng không đi
à à livestream nhiều nhưng không tăng
tốc được rồi ngủ ngon nha Đang nói là
các bạn xem lại cơ đúng không có mưa
livestream Chính vì ở livestream giống
như bạn bè nói livestream thì các bạn
lại cần phải nghe Chắc để mà các bạn
thấm Bởi vì các bạn khó đỡ mất công phải
tua lại tha thứ để mà nghe đúng không
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
Anh Bối Rối chưa quen
Ẩm Thực ra là cái câu này nữa đúng được
không đúng là mình chưa quen việc dậy
đến gần này người cùng một lúc
à à nhưng mình đi dạy ở bây giờ tính ở
hai năm rưỡi cũng như là trước khi nghỉ
ở đấy mình cũng dạy online rồi và mình
cũng nói chuyện à mình cũng thuyết trình
cũng như là mình có có đứng phát biểu
trước toàn trường rồi nên không Nếu
không nói chuyện nào kẹo mình chưa quen
nói chuyện trước đám đông cũng như là
mình không quen việc giận mình dạy cho
vào lỡ buổi tối cho vào người lớn tuổi
hơn rồi nên là mình khẳng định được và
việc mình à
anh bối rối khi dậy đúng không Nhưng
mình có bối rối một chút khi mà nói
chuyện đông người như thế này theo kiểu
là bây giờ mình phải để ý câu từ hơn vì
thế có quay video mà ngon mình nói
chuyện trên lớp thì đôi khi là không
quay video nên mình cứ mạnh gì nói lấy
được không ạ
À mà hôm trước ở mình bị mạng giun thì
công nhận một mình à còn run hơn hôm nay
thì đó không mở điều hòa nữa rồi Tháng
vừa rồi tiền điện hơi nhiều không mở
được điều hòa nữa thôi Nhưng mà bây giờ
chỉ một quạt thôi
à à Anh ở
SMS SMS dùng cho SQL
Em à bây giờ Thôi bây giờ chính thức vào
ban đầu lớp ở đúng không ạ
Em à bây giờ mình sẽ trả lời những cái
câu đấy nhá
có web nào đấy xem qua hôm nay buổi học
hôm nay anh nghỉ quên buổi học hôm nay
là nó có nó có tiêu đề là những ràng
buộc đúng không Thì mình sẽ giải thích
qua cái cái cái đề này trước đã Đầu tiên
là các bạn phải hiểu spi là gì ngon
Apple là đó là chắc cho quay long đích
đó là ngôn ngữ kiểu truy vấn Cai sự kẹo
sự chặt chẽ cái Chắc cho nó kiểu dáng bộ
và nó là thiểu sự chặt chẽ sự cầu kỳ gì
đó mình không chuyên Anh ở đây làm nhé
Mình chỉ Nếu mà dịch ra do dễ hiểu nhất
đấy Nó nào là were nó là làm nó là có
một cấu trúc rất chặt chẽ
ở tại sao mình cứ nhấn mạnh thì sẽ đấy
bởi vì hôm nay mình sẽ học những cái
chặt chẽ của nó
về ngôn ngữ truy vấn có cấu trúc à Chứ
cái Ý mình không phải là cái việc và
ngôn ngữ mà là gì mà lắm với việc cái
cái sự sẽ nó là như thế nào ạ
anh hả Vì mình đọc tiếng Anh chán lắm Kệ
đi Mình chỉ đọc được tài liệu thôi vì
không mình đâu luyện phát âm tiếng anh
đâu đấy một điểm cũng có lợi khi mà các
bạn kiểu kém tiếng Anh mà các bạn học
ngày này thì các bạn cũng không lo sợ có
bị mất gốc hay hay là cậu không nói được
tiếng Anh gì đấy thứ nhất là toàn tiếng
Anh chuyên ngành nên các bạn chỉ cần
quan tâm đến anh trên ngay
như các bạn chẳng lo gì cả các bạn viết
sai chính tả rồi Mấy hôm trước mình biết
đấy thì lên Google Kiểu gì nó cũng sẽ
lại cho Minh đúng gì cả Không phải lo về
việc là bình kèm tiếng Anh đúng không mà
quan trọng là cái này toàn bộ là kiến
thức mới các bạn sẽ phải học đúng không
Các bạn có chịu học hay không thôi
ờ ờ
đấy chị mục lục Hôm nay anh sẽ này các
bạn thấy Hồng không ôn lại mày trả lời
câu hỏi và bài tập mùa trước này
ông bà nội và học qua những ràng buộc
những ràng buộc cái gì em mà thôi cô ấy
video là thương ai trả lời câu hỏi nếu
có thời gian đúng không đầu tiên là mình
mình nghĩ là cứ trả lời câu hỏi trước đã
cho xong này có web nào dậy về cấu trúc
dữ liệu và giải thuật không ạ Con chất
mình có Đề cập về vụ là
ờ ờ các bạn học sp là chuyên sâu thêm
thì sẽ phải cần biết về cấu trúc dữ liệu
và giải thuật cũng như là nói chung là
chuyên sâu về AB thì lương ở sẽ rất là
cao có thử đúng không chúng sẽ có bạn
hỏi vụ này thì tự nhiên là web bây giờ
có đẩy nhưng mà các bạn nên tra này vẫn
lên bằng tiếng Anh có dịch cái cái cái
cụm đấy ra bằng tiếng Anh sau đó thì các
bạn cha
đề tài liệu về ngành Công nghệ thông tin
này có rất nhiều miễn phí nên các bạn
hoàn toàn thì thoải mái cha không sao cả
và đương nhiên là những bản mất tiền thì
đôi khi nó cũng sẽ và chất lượng tốt hơn
một tí giống như những quyển sách như bà
mình nghĩa là các bạn cứ học cơ bản
trước học cái miễn phí trước đã đổi mới
các bạn hình dung nó là gì đã thậm chí
đôi khi ở các bạn nên đọc khoa để xem nó
có đủ tầm các bạn học hay không Trước
khi các bạn nhảy vào học giống như các
bạn trả tiền cho mỗi khóa học sau đó thì
các bạn
em không học được đi thì gọi phí à đúng
không ạ
ở tại sao fa có phần tạo database bằng
các thứ mà phải biết có lệnh đây một câu
cũng rất hay Hồi trước ở Mình đã chính
mình là từng là người khỏi và mình người
làm với thầy của mình đó là rõ ràng là
cái toàn bộ những cái
ở những cái cậu ta mở thẻ Garena
Ừ mình hoàn toàn thì cái này bản chất Nó
là cái tool mà một cái công cụ để mình
hoàn toàn thể thao tác để nâng cao nhanh
Ừ
nó kiểu dạng là kiểu các bạn hoàn toàn
thì tạo bảng bằng bằng hiệu click click
chuột chứ không cần phải đợi tí
à à
ở
đây mình hoàn toàn hệ vào đây để mình
click chuột này Sao lưu ra sân bay nè
xong mình new table có thôi cứ rất là
nhanh các bạn hoàn toàn là không cần
phải gõ hạn có lệnh này ra vẫn được Tại
sao mình phải học câu lệnh Bởi vì thực
sự thì mình học câu lệnh để hiểu bản
chất của nó cũng như là từ sau các bạn
làm việc mà cấp lệnh nó tốt hơn nó dễ dễ
nhìn trực quan và dễ sửa hơn là việc các
bạn dùng bằng tun
Ừ đấy các bạn ma nào giống như các bạn
làm cái trang web bằng tool kéo xả cũng
giống như khác với các bạn làm ăn cốc
đấy Cái này chắc là để các bạn về sau tự
trưng nghiệm sẽ trả lời câu này
ê ê thì bắt đầu học từ đâu Cái ai thì
chắc là mình không học bên đấy nhưng mà
mình thấy thường thì sẽ nói chung cho
các bạn về mọi cái mà các bạn nên bắt
đầu học từ đâu nhé
A lô ga minh ở
tháp phải nhớ thế Tháp
có lộ trình để mà học
lộ trình để học mà
họ lập chi nhánh Mình nhớ không lầm lạc
có hôm trước có bạn cũng chia sẻ về vụ
này có một cái tra đấy là hình như tên
là learn How ạ
à à
em nhớ có cái trang để mà xem được lộ
trình để mà học
Ừ tối mai có mu đá thì có liên quan đến
tối nay đó
cô hiệu trưởng cái trang để mà xem độ
trình học một cái gì đó là trang gì nhé
anh quên mất rồi
em à Đừng glomax À đấy có bạn nhớ rồi
đấy Mát AA
ở đây đây tra ngày để học lộ trình Bật
trình này đây các bạn hoàn toàn bấm vào
đây để xem được là ví dụ Họ bắt em thì
nên học từ Cái gì Cái gì đây Thực ra cái
này trên này nó rộng lắm và lẫn cả đấy
nghiêng các bạn phải biết một tí tiếng
Anh không không hiểu cái gì đúng không
Nhưng mà trên này thì ra rất là rộng
nhưng mà nếu mà các bạn họ cũng cái này
con ngựa cũng rất Vĩ hại
ừ ừ
Ừ cái cái này em các bạn sẽ thấy ví dụ
bác em biết Internet là gì à Xong rồi
kiến thức tí Pharrell rồi cứ
theo ta đến bản bản thân mình nhé bản
thân mình cũng không biết hết rồi Cả
đúng ngay đâu đọc mày đúng ngày đó có
bốn lớn quá
nhưng mà cái này làm một cái một trong
những cái nó là đầy đủ Bởi vì
bởi vì các bạn sẽ thấy đây
Thế bác em từ đầu nhá đến cuối nó có bảo
ship learning nhưng mà ở Bến Tre nó nói
gần như nó khái quát cần như hết rồi
Ê bà cái này thì các bạn học xong cái
này sắp phải là
e56 kinh nghiệm Nam kinh nghiệm đổ lên
là quản lý chậm và hơn thế nữa nhớ đây
cả lộ trình lộ trình đấy à
Ở đây đầy đủ lập trình này học bắt đây
này đúng không nó không bị thừa cái gì
cả
Ừ nhưng mà thực tế là mình đâu có động
hết tất cả đúng ai đó
Ừ mình thật sự đến bản thân mình cũng
không động hết đúng ai mà mình có đi làm
ngon này được Cái này trời ạ lộ trình để
đúng rồi Gần như bạn cứ nói để trở thành
mắt tao ấy cái này hơi xa quá nhưng mà
đây là một cái ý mình Đây là một cái
trang web hoặc cả các bạn hoàn toàn bị
charm áp dụng route-map our
enemies này thì nó sẽ có lộ trình này
chế độ trình vẽ mà biến thành 1
a day in Junior sẽ phải học những cái gì
ra sữa thế đúng không Đây từ khóa các
bạn trai thôi
ở phần mềm
các bạn này phần muốn đi thực tập nhưng
bà ấy chỉ biết HTML CS và switch
Ừ thì từ Ca là cái này nó như này
cô sinh viên Mỹ Đặc Biệt sinh viên bình
thường hay hỏi công ai đó là kéo em biết
được abc xyz rồi Em chỉ được tập được
chưa
Ừ cái việc và các bạn biết càng ít đấy
đúng không Thì đưa như vẫn có thể đi
được nhưng mà bù lại thì ạ
Ừ tùy từng công ty nóng chấp nhận cũng
như là công ty nào nó khỏe
để hỗ trợ việc làm đào tạo cho các bạn
một người mà chưa biết được nhiều lắm
để mà đào tạo các bạn nữa cũng như là nó
trả lương các bạn đôi khi nó ra béo bụng
để mà nó mẫu lột sức lao động các bạn
rất nhiều công ty giờ đang tuyển những
người cần năm kinh nghiệm mà họ bóc lột
kinh khổ thế nên là
thì mình nghĩ là các bạn nên cỏ có kiến
thức nó phải tầm tầm thì đó cũng là phải
anh đi làm một cái gì đó
thực tế làm hàm một cái sản phẩm nho nhỏ
thực tế để mà các bạn là trau dồi được
kinh nghiệm từ chính tại nhà sau đó thì
các bạn mình nên đi thực tập để có những
thứ việc khoe và cũng như là
những kiểu tạo và họ sẽ cảm thấy kiểu
Thái có đam mê thằng này đã làm được cái
gì đó ổn rồi thì nó sẽ khác sau ý Kiều
Em chưa làm được cái gì cả Em chưa học
toàn bộ lý thuyết cơ bản thôi Ừ thì lúc
đấy Họ sẽ sẽ cân nhắc đấy Họ sẽ cân nhắc
một là họ không nhận lại bạn luôn hay là
họ sẽ hỏi những cái câu mà nó hơi mang
kiến thức có thể là hàn lâm hay là kiến
thức kiểu để mà đánh giá xem bạn là một
người tư duy hay không và những cái câu
hỏi đấy
chứ không phải là lúc nào bạn trả lời
được và tỷ lệ trượt nó vẫn sẽ cao đúng
không
Bởi vì đôi khi ở họ hoặc xem xét giờ
khi họ hỏi bạn luôn họ Trừ khi bạn Giỏi
vãi chưởng Thôi trả lời hết và họ thế
Hay lắm họ tuyển Còn không thì họ sẽ
luôn bảo em về nhà thì xem đã sau đó đi
họ sẽ xem ứng Cửu cử viên khác tốt hơn
này không Vân Vân đúng không các bạn sẽ
biến thành một lựa chọn cho họ mà thành
ra là
kể cái buổi phỏng vấn đấy Nó gần như là
sẽ lại càng là một cái rào cản hơn cho
các bạn để các bạn cảm thấy áp lực trong
ngày này bởi vì các bạn phỏng vấn quá
nhiều lần rồi cận thì các bạn sẽ bị nạn
sinh viên mình đầy rẫy ra mình biết mà
sinh viên mình toàn kiểu tham ham hồ mới
học xong chưa chưa làm được một cái gì
đó nôn để mà khoe Các bạn ơi đã đi thực
tập rồi và đi thực tập xong rồi nộp CV ở
nhiều nơi mãi mình có một nơi gọi đi tôi
không phỏng vấn phỏng vấn đi thấy họ bảo
là sẽ trả lời sau cũng không được ngày
mấy bạn An
ạ Bây giờ trường nào đào tạo công nghệ
thông tin khẳng định thì các bạn hơn
những cái bạn kia ở điểm gì Chán thế
Ừ thì các bạn hơn những bạn đấy việc các
bạn phải thể hiện mình đam mê hơn trước
các bạn thể hiện gì nữa đúng không ạ
à à
em muốn viết chương trình để quản lý thế
này thì người ta viết hẳn bằng phần mềm
để truy vấn dữ liệu của tốt hơn không
đây một câu rất là hay không biết được
là bạn lấy hỏi có phải hỏi móc mình
không thì không biết yêu mình cứ trả lời
thành thật nhé đó là à
Ừ nếu mà ai chưa hiểu ý câu hỏi bọn đấy
nó sẽ như thế này đó là thay vì kiểu
Mình cứ mình cứ Giống như mình lập trình
Hôm trước có bạn bảo lại Insert bây giờ
sự em có sẵn tập khách hàng 100.000
khách hàng rồi thì em bảo em ngồi gõ câu
lệnh Insert đến trăm nghìn lần à Thôi
thế đúng không Tại sao không có hẳn một
cái phần mềm sau đó thì mình kiểu Ấn một
nút mình nhập file Excel vào mí rất là
đây đấy người vào đúng không ạ đề thi
cái này là cái thứ chính là cái thứ mà
về sau mình sẽ học lập trình để mình làm
đó vui bây giờ mình đang học cái nền ta
để biết về các câu lệnh sau đó mình sẽ
Chuyển qua ngôn ngữ Lập trình là sẽ kết
nối đến Cái này sử dụng câu lệnh ngay
xong rồi để mạ Insert vào hai bề mạnh
các thứ thứ nhanh hơn thì chả
khoa học fa có thể chống lại Apple rét
rừng không Ừ cái câu này thì ra là vì
sau các bạn mấy thiểu được FeS là gì
nhưng mà
Anh Bình khờ đẻ đầy để mà trả lời nhanh
Các bạn cho bạn làm à ạ thắc mắc thì có
Ừ nó là bài toán về việc là các bạn học
khách nhưng mà để để phòng thủ thay vì
tấn công em ạ thì cái này Thế các bạn
học lập trình để biết được và lỗ hổng ở
đâu để các bạn
Ừ để các bạn tránh tránh mắc phải những
cái lỗi đấy
Ừ anh giải thích cái ác
Ừ nó để làm gì hôm trước mình có đề cập
phải vụ có cả shopee mình sẽ dùng shopee
hoặc lagon hoặc cả mấy cái kiểu như này
này ngon mấy cái này chẳng qua nó làm
môi trường để mình kết nối đến đã sắp
bây vậy mà để mà truy vấn và thao tác
với dữ liệu thôi
này còn có thêm cả máy ảo vậy mà chạy
chạy mấy cái đây nữa
Ừ nếu mình nhập 120000₫ tuổi đây đây thì
mình có vừa để cập đúng không Đó là mình
không nên kiểu
mình ghi một lần 1.000 lần câu lệnh
Insert đúng không Mình sẽ về thì mình
phải lập trình để mang kiểu mình nhập
vào danh sách rất nhanh rất tiện đúng
không
em có bạn này hỏi này mã sinh viên của
các trường đại học làm gì thì đơn giản
thế nhờ ngon bỏ vì hôm trước mình có đề
cập đó là mã sinh viên Mã thường ăn mặc
định tự động tăng chẳng hạn thế Ở đây
bài tập của bạn khác Nhưng xin lỗi mình
mở lại bài của mình hôm trước nhé
a mã của mình hôm trước này và mã tự
động tăng này thì nên thi tự động tăng
này khi bạn ấy thắc mắc là mã sinh viên
của các trường đại học đôi khi nó na ná
giống như mã đến trường Bình sẽ
pk012
pk001 mà cái gì đó Làm thế nào để mã nó
ra như này thận chứa mã sinh viên nó còn
thêm cả khóa nữa ra sửa khóa k10 này
khóa 11 này trả lại nó sẽ như thế này
Thế làm thế nào để mà mình cậu mình ra
được cái như thế này thậm chí là cả còn
bên cả ngày nữa sửa nhàng bên ngành lập
trình được ạ khi nó sẽ
lập trình
bk001 k11 Chừng nào xong rồi lập trình
dk000 hay các bạn cũng hiểu ý mình mà
đúng không cái bản chất là ra được cái
khóa này anh ra được cái mã này thì bản
chất là mình nói thôi mình nối nó với
nhau đầu tiên này Các bạn nhìn thấy qua
mình sẽ nói cái mã ngành là lập trình
sau đó em thêm cái chữ pk rồi lại hiểu
Nó tên trường trường Bách Khoa Gì đấy
đúng không sau đó thì kém số này số này
sẽ ra số mình lưu lại này trong bảng mã
này mà cuối cùng cái này là khóa khóa
này cũng định sẽ tách ra một cột ghi âm
nói chung
cho tất cả các cái này mình sẽ cách các
cột ghi âm anh tưởng Sau đó mình sẽ nối
lại với nhau chứ không phải là mình lưu
lại
để lưu lại mã cả cục một cục như thế này
chưa Bởi vì Giả sử bạn ấy vậy bị đốt em
ạ thì bạn đấy bản chất là quá khóa thì
phải thay đổi Đúng không các thử bạn
chua Cái này là liên quan hơi bị liên
quan đến bên về sau một tí ạ Mình sẽ
giảm Vì sao về sau Tại sao lại như thế
sau khi
I Delete from có cần ít axit hay không
đem có giữa hai này cho bạn đi qua cái
vụ đấy nhá không hiểu lắm
Tại sao bạn ấy phải Đề cập về vụ ipass
là kiểm tra có tồn tại không thì là
Delete này là không cần kiểm tra tồn tại
này dùng cho xử lý sẽ nhắc lại các bạn
xem nhé đây thật sự là mình có ba bạn
như thế này đúng không ạ sử mình sẽ
Delete whey bạn có mã bằng 10 ạ bạn sẽ
thấy là không có bạn nào có mã 10 cả nó
vẫn không bảo lỗi nó bảo là chẳng qua
không xóa được bạn nào không có bạn ghi
là bị tác động không sợ không xóa được
bạn nào thôi đúng không ạ Ừ cái Delete
này nó là thấy nó không cần phải kiểm
tra gì cả vẫn sẽ xóa và nhiễm mà nói
theo kiểu cách Văn vợ hơn ý đó là kiểu
như thế này mình sẽ mở cái cách SEO lên
thì các bạn xem qua nhé là sử đây có mã
này có tên sinh viên này tên này có tuổi
em ạ sư thấy đâu nhé Một này Long này
U20 này
ở đâu 20 chứ Anh Tuấn ngày hai mươi mấy
giờ xử như thế này sao bây giờ sửa mình
sẽ xóa những bạn để mình sẽ in late for
sinh viên Này
Where tuổi bằng 20 trở lại cho xử ngay
thì mình sẽ hiểu nếu mình chạy cái này
mình sẽ hiểu là mình nhìn qua ở đây thì
mình biết được ngay là người nào sẽ bị
xóa rồi đúng không Nhưng giả sử cái bảng
này có lên đến Hàng trăm nghìn triệu bản
ghi nghe các bạn sẽ không nhìn được hết
mà máy nó sẽ làm hộ các bạn vụ đầy đúng
không Thế mày anh sẽ xử lý bài toán ở
đấy nó như thế nào quan trọng như thế
đúng không đầu tiên nó có xóa này đi
không đã quan trọng ở thế đúng không
anh hả mà xa cái bạn em sẽ mạnh đầu tiên
ấy không
anh không đúng không
Ừ Thế làm sao mà các bạn hiểu được nó sẽ
xóa bạn này mà không phải bạn này
Thế giờ chắc là hỏi thỉnh thoảng hỏi rồi
Dừng lại một tí các bạn trả lời cho nó
tập trung không
ô hay cái gì Tập trung vào vấn đề đi anh
anh em trả lời tôi có gọi đi anh đi anh
có xóa bạn Long này không đúng không
cách chạy lệnh này thì xóa bạn Long này
không
ở bảng và Tại sao các bạn hiểu là trận
lệnh nghệ xóa bạn thứ hai
có điều kiện đúng không có bạn bè cần
phải điều kiện đúng không
có điều kiện ở đây Xóa là theo
anh xóa theo tuổi đúng không Tức là ở
đây bài toán các bạn vừa nói thì nó đơn
giản thôi đúng không Đó là mình kiểm tra
trong tủ lạnh trong cái điều kiện này có
có hợp lý không Có thỏa mãn hay không
thì nó mới chạy gì đúng không Tức là
mình lấy cô tuổi ra đúng không Rồi mình
so sánh nó với 20 Đúng chưa thì các bạn
sẽ thấy nó thỏa mãn thì nó mới xóa đúng
không
ăn thịt tất cả đây bài toán nó luôn là
chạy từ trên xuống dưới và nó sẽ luôn
kiểm tra đến từng cái hành một đến từng
hành một nó lại kiểm tra điều kiện lại
một lần nữa
em và nó mới xóa Tại sao tự nhiên mình
để cặp vụ hiển nhiên ở đấy ở đây và lý
do sử gia sư ở đây mình có bạn tên là Ba
bạn này tên là à Nam đi
em 21 tuổi chẳng hạn
ờ ờ
cách xóa bạn Tuấn ở đúng không Bạn Nam
này có bị xóa không
các bạn nam này có bị xóa không
anh kia mình chạy lại câu lệnh này
ở đây mày cái câu mà rõ ràng nó chuyển
Nhiên đúng không Nhưng mà các bạn cứ trả
lời mình đi Rồi mình sẽ chạy mình sẽ nói
nói nói Tại sao
đó là các bạn có thể trả lời ngay không
nó không phải nó quá Hiền điên rồi tuổi
không bằng 20 thì thôi đúng không Ừ thì
đúng nhưng mà ở đây mình hỏi lại các bạn
nhé
ờ ờ rõ ràng mình bảo chạy từ trên xuống
dưới rồi đúng không
các bạn đầu tiên không thỏa mãn ok rồi
bạn thứ hai có thỏa mãn tức là que tên
bằng 20 rồi đúng không
Thế thì tại sao nhảy xuống bạn thứ ba
cái thỏa mãn này nó lại bị mất đi
Thì rõ là cái tuổi bằng 20 thỏa mãn ở
trên đó mà Thì ở dưới nó vẫn phải thỏa
mãn chứ
có đúng không tại sao ở dưới nó lại
thành không thỏa mãn
Ừ
vậy sao
Anh nói có bạn hỏi thêm một câu hai nữa
kìa mình sẽ trả lời mình bị hủy sẽ hỏi
và cập đây các bạn trả lời điều kiện
Đúng rồi có bạn nói câu rất hay kìa đúng
rồi xét lại định kiện Chạy điều kiện
đúng rồi nó dễ hiểu thì thôi đúng không
đấy các bạn thấy hiển nhiên nhưng mà các
bạn phải trả lời được cái câu hình nhiên
đấy nó giống kiểu bây giờ mình bắt các
bạn giải thích một cộng một bằng hai cái
sao vậy các bạn coi nó hiển nhiên nhưng
đôi khi các bạn không trả lời được nó
đâu đúng không
thì các bạn sẽ xét lại điều kiện không
chính xác là các bạn sẽ kiểm tra lại cái
cột tuổi lần này các bạn sẽ phải lấy
tuổi mới chứ không phải lấy tuổi ở trên
ở Ngọc chưa
em heo anh Tuấn à
Ở
đây các bạn sẽ kiểm tra lại tuổi thêm
một lần nữa để xem nó thỏa mãn hay không
nó ngon đấy và đương nhiên lần này tuổi
nó không còn thỏa mãn nữa nên nó sẽ
không xóa đến tận thế thôi Đúng chưa tập
trung vào đây đi thì toàn cười sau khi
cười thì các bạn phải quay lại bắt nhịp
nhanh chứ ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ đấy Bà Ok giờ sự Xóa em Chừng nào mày
đúng không này thầy hiệu trưởng váy màu
rồi đấy bây giờ đến câu thứ hai mà bạn
kia vừa nãy bạn đấy có hỏi câu rất hay
mà mình đang định cũng sẽ hỏi các bạn đó
là
à à
cách xóa bản thử xóa bạn thứ hai đúng
không Thì mã của bạn này có quay lại
bằng hai đúng không
anh Bởi vì rõ ràng mã tự động tăng móng
Theo các bạn mã quay lại bằng 202 nó vẫn
bằng 3
Khi
Nào tập trung gần đây nào
khi thầy hiệu trưởng chỉ giỏi làm sao
nhãng học sinh rồi
anh không đúng không có không có không
có không
khi đôi bài toán đề để mình trả lời cho
bạn nhé nó vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên thì chưa
thấy sao vì bài toán ở đây đó là xóa này
bản chất nó chỉ duyệt Tâm thằng từng
Hoàng một rồi nó cho bay những cái thằng
nào mà kiểu không thỏa mãn điều kiện
thôi chứ nó không reset lại cả cái bảng
nó không cập nhật lại cái cột mã giờ
cho nên là một mã nó hay là tất cả cục
khác vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên bây giờ không
thay đổi cái gì cả ở đây tiếp theo bài
toán nó như thế này
ở bên nó bán ba đúng không
Bây giờ giả sử mình Insert
into sinh viên này ạ thêm một bạn nữa gì
đó thì treo các bạn mã bạn đấy sẽ bằng 2
à hay là bằng 4
Ừ đúng rồi bạn kia nói đúng rồi thì tao
khóa chính trong trường hợp này không
liên quan gì cả chị em sợ nó không giấy
sẽ lại cô đấy thôi
cô bé trả lời tiếp nào mã nó sẽ bằng hai
bằng 4
thì nó sẽ những kiểu lấp đầy cái chỗ này
hay nó sẽ lên 4
à à
thì các bạn trả lời thế bằng 40 bạn là
trời hay à các bạn tình phết nhỉ Ok
trong trường hợp này nó sẽ mà nó sẽ lên
và buồn đúng không ta sẽ tự động tăng
đúng không thứ tự động tăng theo cái
hàng lớn nhất để nạn thôi đúng không ạ
Ừ cái này sắc hả
các bạn cũng hiểu hình dung được lá đúng
không
Ừ Thì bây giờ mình à
thì mình tiếp tục những cái
ở đây
đã có câu này
em chọn số bắt đầu để tăng dần Không
phải là một thì sao ạ
cậu ấy Thực ra là một cái câu trị chuyên
sâu hơn thôi nhưng mà có có trường hợp
với như thế giờ sự các bạn muốn mã bắt
đầu tự động tăng không phải từ một thậm
chí là các bạn thì từ siêu âm cũng được
thì cái này liên quan đến các bạn xét
như xe ta
à à
Có ai đi
agreement nhớ đấy
chứ không phải set
a beginner ạ
I live in Zalo này
ở đây
chi phí nhất là các bạn có thể để cho nó
tăng lên không phải là một giá trị nữa
các bạn thể tăng 100 do chị
áo kiểu số số tiếp theo cách số đầu tiên
là 100 và chỉ cũng được họ vẫn chia các
bạn có thể cho nó kiểu dạng là bắt đầu
từ số bao nhiêu Số bao nhiêu này thì có
bạn sẽ khai báo kiểu Nga đã từ khóa trà
nhé em mình sẽ chỉ nói qua thế các bạn
trai luôn nhé Thì
a tiếp theo chính thì có phụ không đúng
không bạn vậy khóa khóa phụ thì có chức
năng gì coi là một cặp rất hay và lại
rất nhiều sinh viên mình mắc phải nhưng
mà mình xin phép đây chị em bật mí Thôi
để một buổi sau mình trả lời bởi vì buổi
hôm nay ra mình không Mình chỉ học đến
cái này các bạn là cứ bạn nào tò mò thì
các bạn thì tra trước nhé
à à toán áp dụng và lập trình thường là
phần nào vậy anh ra toán cái này nó nói
hơi rộng một tí toán là bản chất nó là
các bạn học cái đấy để các bạn gần như
là
khi trứng rụng và công nghệ thông tin
này là các bạn chủ yếu ở cái tư duy hơn
là việc và các bạn tính toán vì nó không
còn à
ừ ừ
Ừ thì các bạn học toán để có cái tư duy
để làm cái thứ hơn đây các bạn thì nói
đúng đấy không mọi khóa phụ đâu mà chỉ
có
chợ khoa ngoại và
I và phát trí rồi không có khóa phụ đâu
chú
ý mày như thế có rất nhiều bạn bị nhầm
kiểu các bạn cứ Nghĩa có chính như có
phụ nhưng mà không
khi mình thực tập ở đâu Cái này chắc là
đến cuối giờ có bạn nào đó nhắc mình hộ
mình phát để mình sẽ tôi trả lời các bạn
với cái câu lý do mà mình An ninh thứ kể
qua về bản thân mình đi làm như nào thấy
nên tập trung câu hỏi để mọi người tương
tác cao hơn mà nói chuyện linh tinh
ngoài này Đây đây không Mình mình có ai
cập ngay từ đầu video đấy ngủ ngon là
Ừ đúng rồi bây giờ mình sẽ đặt các bạn
có hỏi nhiều hơn thì các bạn tương tác
và nói chuyện bên lễ bên lệ ra là để các
bạn cảm thấy gần gũi hay nói chung các
bạn có góc nhìn khác thì dân công nghệ
thôi nhưng mà đúng là nó hơn ngoài lời
thật nó vẫn là tính và ngoại lệ thế nên
là mình trong đấy buổi video về mình sẽ
trong một tiếng mình dậy còn ngoài một
tiếng này ra thì mình sẽ nói chuyện
ngoài Lê chưa
[âm nhạc]
số điện thoại
anh nghe em
ở trong
ở trong một cô check của công ty anh
thường hay làm gì cái này cái này chắc
là mình tí để sao mình mình
bận tí có tiếng điện thoại ở đâu
họ đậu xanh không anh
[âm nhạc]
Ở
chu mi
bộ phim
Ừ ok nãy giờ hơi bị lòng vòng vòng vòng
rồi mình cảm thấy hơi bị lòng vòng quá
mình bây giờ đầu tiên mình khuyến mềm
Trang à
Bị sincere ơn fe3o
ừ ừ
chị sẽ lên trang này
để cho có bạn xem với cái những cái răng
buộc hôm nay mình thì sẽ bị dạy nó chính
là cái con Jae con cũng không biết đọc
cái từ này là gì thì sẽ gặp con chó cho
anh nhé Chắc thế
Cái này là những cái ràng buộc những cái
kiểu
ở những cái gọi quy định ở trong SQL
anh ở đây mình có đề cập thêm là trong
Apple server gì và ở bên trái thì nó sẽ
là đối với máy queo Nếu mà ý nghĩa thì
nó là nó là của cả hai nhé trong ý mình
trong xvideo server thì nó có hay không
Hay là có gì đó gì gì đó thì mình sẽ
được gặp cụ thể ở đây thì chưa
ở
tại sao ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy còn những
cái khái niệm là không chấp mình có ai
cập unic nó duy nhất này được chưa Thì
là dữ liệu không được phép lặp lại nó
kiểu thế là sử là bây giờ mình có đề cập
Vụ
này mình tạm dốc cái bà đi này mình sẽ
cho tên là unique này nó là uy que nick
này chả đoạn này
nó báo thành công đúng không Bây giờ này
mình sẽ cho tên hai người giống hệt nhau
à cũng thấy Long này
khi chạy thử này
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là
à à
thì nó sẽ báo lỗi ở đây đó là không được
phép trùng tên trùng chưa đấy tên đang
lập lại giá trị Long này Đấy uốn nick nó
Chị có bạn nó như thế nó không được phép
lặp lại được bơ hỏi ngang qua cho các
bạn trả lời nhanh nhé Theo các bạn
300 lại không nên bỏ qua đây theo các
bạn là unique được phép luôn không
a nhớ nút là giống
anh luôn vào hôm trước mình từng hỏi là
là tình nói là
có giá trị không dẫn là
em có người yêu nhưng mà bị chia tay rồi
còn luôn là theo cậu là fa chưa từng có
người yêu ấy ý Ừ thì theo các bạn là cái
cột mà nó là unic thì được phép luôn hay
không
a nay có có bạn trả lời có cả có và
không đúng không Thì câu trả lời Hôm
trước ở thời ca ngay từ đầu mình có nói
qua yankee thì ta mình có đề cập rồi
chào bạn có bạn quên mất rồi khoai Mochi
fire phim
hoạt hình Đúng không Nó sẽ bằng unique
Cậu ngồi lót núi Tức là sao
nghĩa là Yoona có thể nun thế nên là
khoai Mickey nó chị khác với uống thích
là điểm là ý là nó có là nó là cộng thêm
về nó luôn rồi đúng không
anh đúng không được có bạn nhớ kia em
chưa Ờ
e và
và đương nhiên là Yoona có thể nun chỉ
được luôn một lần bởi vì nó vẫn ông ấy
nick mày đúng không đấy à
nhà mình có ai cập ở đây cho mình tiếp
theo khóa ngoại này phó mạnh thì buổi
sau mình sẽ học nhé Đây cái nút luôn này
thì các bạn phải thêm cái này vào thì
các bạn mới bắt buộc cột đấy không được
nun Giả sử ở đây các bạn rõ ràng thấy là
phải mình tặng khuyết lại phát nữa đây
tạm ổn định đi nhé ạ
ở tận gốc vấn đề
đi quét lại
Ừ thôi lần này mình sẽ đi xuất một bạn
thôi nhưng mà mình không truyền tên là
bạn ấy càng ạ không chuyển tiền luôn đi
sợ này
thì các bạn thấy vẫn thành công đúng
không
ở tại sao Bởi vì khi mình xem xe lách
lại này Ok tên mình đang luôn tên của
bạn đang luôn cái À thế này không không
tốt đúng không cái này à
vì nó không chặt chẽ nó không ràng buộc
với cái gì cả ràng buộc ở đây là tên nó
phải không được để trống Chẳng thế đúng
không thì gọi sẽ thấy là ở đây nó luôn
này thì thêm vào đó các bạn thấy màu
khác luôn nó gợi ý thêm màu khác vì vậy
đúng không và những cái
những cái mà các bạn muốn bắt buộc phải
đi ăn thì các bạn sẽ phải thêm chụp nude
luôn vào để bắt buộc phải điền chứ không
để trường hợp luôn nghe được cũng chưa
Ok cái này cho các bạn hiểu rồi mà đúng
không đấy thì ra sự rơi tình với Tính
bắt buộc phải điền này chẳng hạn số điện
thoại bắt buộc phải điền này ngày sinh
bác Hồ thể hiện Nói chung là nhớ ra sự
các bạn muốn bắt buộc phải đến hết thì
các bạn phải ghi nó luôn tất cả các cột
- Copa Mickey thì hiển nhiên là nó nôn
rồi ông ạ Cái Đốt Lại chạy nè
Em in soát lại các bạn sẽ thấy báo lỗi
là cột tên không được nung Đúng chưa đái
gì chưa
em phải nóng dễ hiểu mà đúng không
a tiếp theo ăn sai
Ừ nếu ăn sai dịch ra ấy thì nó sẽ là
không có ký tự nhưng mà bé dịch thu ô
Còn nếu mà
à à
Ừ nếu mà
chuẩn đấy thì nó là không có dấu trừ nhé
Không được với âm cái này thì ra là xong
mai que thì mới có trong Apple server
mình có tra đấy mình có cha em giao
server aâu MF mới đúng ăn sai đấy
Tại sao thằng fg server không hỗ trợ kẻ
ăn sai tức là tại sao
ở đây đầu tiên thì giải thích tại sao
cái ăn xanh này có lợi điểm gì Ngoài
việc có số không được phép âm ra nó còn
làm gấp đôi cái giới hạn của số đấy bởi
vì hôm trước mình có đề cập Nếu mà hiểu
in thì số sẽ là âm 2 tỷ sắp xỉ ngầm 2 tỷ
sau đầy Bình Dương 2 tỷ thì chưa nhưng
mà nếu mà các bạn thêm cái ăn say vào
thì tốt nhất là không phải phát âm thứ
hai nó sẽ giới hạn của nó sẽ bắt đầu từ
0 cho đến hơn 4 tỷ nghĩa nó sẽ gấp đôi
thế giới hạn nó lên đấy đấy điểm có lợi
việc ăn sai mà vừa kiểu kiểm tra không
âm vừa lắm kiểu nó sẽ cắt cái đoạn bộ
nhớ để mà lưu số âm Ngồi trước cộng và
cái số Dương Thành ra giới hạn số dương
và Phan Minh gấp đôi được ngon thì
Ừ cái bạn em bảng này thì chắc là các
bạn không không để ý rồi ra là mình có
ghi phần trong mô tả của cái video luôn
có tất cả những video các bạn cần rồi
thì mình cứ nhắn lại nhé đơn Fe này
ở đó
Ừ chắc thi
thì gầy ăn xa này ở bên ép cao server nó
không hỗ trợ
anh có một ông trả lời đây
Vì sao rồi ông ấy Nói tóm tắt lại đây là
tao không sửa Tại sao còn nếu dài giọng
hơn của của ông ấy nói thì ông ấy bảo là
việc
có thêm hẳn một cái kiểu dữ liệu cốt chỉ
để kiểm tra âm hay không nó thấy là
không cần thiết thế nên nói chung Tóm
lại là nó không thèm xưởng đấy chữ cái
câu hỏi này được hỏi thứ là lâu rồi
vì
con cái mà tại sao cái vụn sau để mình
có đề cập ở đây bởi vì à về sau mình sẽ
học sáng máy khuya thì nó có thêm vụ oan
sai và các bạn cũng nên dùng cái vụn xa
này cho một vài cột kiểu số nguyên các
bạn vì ví dụ cụt mã là các bạn này chẳng
hạn nghe cột mã này các bạn thứ như là
nó tự động tăng rồi đúng không Tự động
tăng thì các bạn hình như là nó sẽ không
được âm ở đúng không thì các bạn thêm
một cái nó ăn sai để kiểm tra Chắc cho
nó khô ngâm nữa này và để cho nó sẽ lên
giới hạn lên hẳn 4 tỷ chứ phải hái tỷ
chẳng hạn thế cơm chưa
anh không ẩm thực ra ông ấy trả lời đấy
nghe cháu về cục xúc thì thôi Nhưng mà
ông đứng nhờ các bạn thấy ta bây giờ
thêm một cái gì đó nó sẽ bị nặng và nó
sẽ có thể thay đổi ở nhiều chỗ làm cho
bài toán phức tạp hơn Vì sao các bạn Làm
lập trình các bạn sẽ hiểu là đôi khi
khách hàng thì sẽ nghĩ là ngồi cái đoạn
này ngắn dễ mà anh thêm một tí với em mà
xong nhưng mà
sau khi mà làm được chỉnh các bạn dí
hiểu thêm một cái đôi khi nó ảnh hưởng
tới chỗ khác thì nó và mình phải cân
nhắc xem nó có cần thiết hay không bài
toán không trước mình có nói rồi nó 20
80 Nếu mà giờ sử 20 phần trăm người dùng
cần cái đấy thì có thể mình không nên
làm Bởi vì đôi khi làm mặt tội tốn 80
phần trăm tài nguyên
cho nên nó không
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo kiểu số thực này
đây là flash cho các bạn biết rồi Ba cha
chú ấy nè tra chuỗi này một lần là kiểu
đúng sai iPhone đưa một con không đúng
không Nếu mà ở trong Access server thì
sẽ ghi là bit ngon chứ không phải là bú
Liên đ
khi
tách lại ngon cách chỉ có thêm n-tek
Anh ở cái đoạn này mình bị copy nhầm
xuống dưới à ơi mình bị copy n-tek phải
ở trên này mới đúng chứ lỗi
tủ
bếp time time này các bạn sẽ thấy là có
biết là ngày tháng năm trước mình có đề
cập dụng này xinh đúng không
có thêm cả vết ham là ngày tháng năm giờ
phút giây nhưng mà nó sẽ cách ra một cái
như này sau đó đi giờ thế này đúng không
Ê bà ở đây hôm nay mình sẽ để cập cái vụ
này cho các bạn về cái ràng buộc nó cái
check vào cái phone không phải chỉ mỗi
Cún nghị unix và nó nôn như thế này mà
mình sẽ có một cái về cái trách và Cái
phô chưa
Ừ cái này để để làm cái vụ này thì mình
sẽ chữa bài tập cho bộ Hôm trước đã nhé
mình sẽ chữa bài tập hôm trước trước đi
để các bạn dễ hình dung Thật bởi vì bài
tập của mình sẽ gần như sẽ sẽ có nhắc
những cái kiến thức mà hung hôm sau sẽ
học chưa Và chắc Lần sau các bạn dí
nghiện mà không bình luận vào đây câu
trả lời nhé Hơi buồn Các bạn vào bình
luận thì các bạn chị sợ các bạn kia có
cốt chạy không
khi xét lại giá trị bằng hai để mà về mà
sắp xếp ra mình trước thử vụ đấy bao giờ
Ừ nhưng mà cái vụ tự động tăng của thằng
ép Wow đấy mình nhớ chính xác nó sẽ lấy
một lấy cái mã lớn nhất để nó tự động
tăng thế nên là cho dù bây giờ các bạn
xét lại nó bằng hai để mà đi sớm thì nó
nó tự động tăng nó vẫn sẽ không thành
hay đâu cơm chưa
Anh nhớ nó thế con không biết được là à
thực tế nó chính sắc như mình nói không
tôi khi mình nhớ một chuyện thôi
thì các bạn nhấn để mà biến nó thành chủ
thích thì control KC nó sẽ biến chú
thích này đấy
ờ ờ
để tạo một bảng nên thông tin khách hàng
mà Vân Vân này thêm 5 khách hàng này mấy
câu cơ bản này cần chỗ nghỉ cho mình cứ
chữa hết nhé
quyết thấy bồ đó ngon Hôm nay mình sẽ có
cả vụ Yoona hay các từ thứ mẹ sẽ bạn
quen khách hàng này thì có mã này kiểu
nè MTP tự động tăng này
họ họ tên nó họ tên
in3 tra
Chọn 50 thoải mái đúng không
Số điện thoại
tra đấy 15 trở lại địa chỉ giảm nợ tách
là thực ra nào tách ra vẫn còn lớn đấy
vì đó tách là nó lưu vụ rất nhiều các
bạn thể cân nhắc giữa n vectra tầm 200
thôi chị ạ Cho đến nơ tách tùy nó tách
thì các bạn không cần được khai báo Ấn
Độ dài lớn nhất
thế giới tính
cho biết mày và ngày sinh đúng không Hãy
xin bếp thì các bạn sẽ phải thêm mọi chữ
lót luôn ở đằng sau này sẽ là thế
a
lot Mun mẹ
gnula.nu lại nó luôn này sẽ nặn hết và
do sử số điện thoại để các bạn muốn
tránh việc nó lặp lại thì có bạn sẽ thêm
4 lít đúng không chị số điện thoại không
được phép dùng chán thế
à à ngày sinh
À tao hiểu nghỉ hoài mới khi một mã
có bạn có thể khóc mà thăm nhưng mình
trả lời luôn mà giả sử các bạn muốn kiểm
tra việc địa chỉ nó cũng tránh chung em
ạ Thực ra là nếu mà các bạn mình nào
Tech thì nó không hỗ trợ nó không hỗ trợ
các bạn muốn ít ở đấy đâu Tại sao vì nó
rất nắp khi mà kiểm tra bởi vì nào tách
này có thể một đoạn văn bản rất dài nó
có thể chạy từ đầu đến cuối thì kiểm tra
xem cả cái đoạn văn bản Đấy khớp một cái
đoạn cả một cái cục văn bản khác không
thì nên là
một nửa tách thì nó không hỗ trợ vụ nick
đâu nhé đấy đi
à à
cách giải nhanh gọn và dễ hiểu Bác không
lấy Giờ mình đang thấy mình đang bị dài
dòng ra nên mình đang chuẩn bị phải
ai chạy nhanh một tí không Trước hết
sưng một tiếng lại chưa học được cái gì
mới đi
ở đời mình chạy thử này
ê kê đúng không đi sẽ insight into Khách
hàng chuyển họ tên số điện thoại
địa chỉ
xe máy tính và ngày sinh của
nó à
à à
ở địa chỉ giới tính không cần
phải này
em copy đó
ở xa lắm mày ạ
a123 đã
Hà Nội
ở
một mảnh trăm nghìn
0101 này
sản
phẩm này
à 24
Hải Phòng này
anh không ạ
à à anh không Anh nhớ cũng sinh này này
vậy
ở Hà Đông 1947 Quế ý
à còn gì nhỉ anh À đúng rồi Các bạn nên
nhớ là trong đề bài có cái gì các bạn
mình cho thêm vào nhé Không đôi kia các
bạn ý suốt xong rồi Toàn nhìn lại đề bài
kiểu thấy nhưng có lo ông sinh trước như
này thôi có ông tên như này không ra
được đúng không các bạn xem lại nhé gọi
tiền anh này nó ok rồi tình nam cứ tự
thử Ok không
ừ ừ
Anh à Hồ Chí Minh Cảnh
năm 1996 thể Ok 1996 à
Cho coi phim cứ in shop 3 bạn trước nha
mình nói à
anh kể hiển thị chị họ tên và số điện
thoại của tất cả khách hàng đúng không
anh lại bị copy bình thường anh copy như
này cái đề bài Nhìn nó rõ nè
cho
chị họ tên mình sẽ có snack họ
Ê bà số điện thoại họ tên và số điện
thoại không đúng không form
xe khách hàm thế xong lấy chỉ có họ tên
và số điện thoại in ra thôi đúng không
Ok rồi yêu đúng không tiếp theo
Ai Cập nhật khách hàng có mã là hay sang
tên Tuấn Ừ
anh tên sư khi xưa Tuấn rồi Nhưng không
sao Mình Cập nhật lại vì nó không bảo
lỗi mà nó vẫn thế là được đúng không anh
sẽ update khách hàng test tên họ tên
đúng không ạ a
n Tuấn
Where
mã bằng 2a
Ai Cập nhật này xài thử sẽ lấy lại nhé
Anh tên vẫn thế không đổi gì cả tất cả à
vẫn chạy được đúng không
ông xã
anh
xóa khách hàng có mã lớn hơn 3 và giới
tính là Nam đúng không ở Mỹ suốt lại
phát nữa nhé
em xem lại phát nữa Tuy nhiên là sẽ báo
lỗi vì
đang bị lọc cái 123 số điện thoại đúng
không xử mình Insert 1 bạn cũng tên là
Long đi
mà mong fb cả số điện thoại 134 Đó ok
rồi này và lần này mình sẽ Delete đ
xe ôm khách hàng E mã lớn hơn ba em và
mà đúng và sẽ có em đúng không
a a giới tính bằng 1
em có bạn hỏi mình đó là
thế giới tính cả Nam thì anh phải ghi
chữ Nam chứ tại sao ghi một đúng không
Và vì mình quy ước ở trong mình quý ở
trong này Nó là một cái rồi đúng không
Nhưng mình làm Thế còn nếu mà các bạn
muốn truyền hẳn Nam vào và nó vẫn xóa
những chặng thằng một ý thì cái này là
mình nên liên quan đến bên lập trình
nhiều hơn và hơn trong Excel thu như thế
này bởi vì nó là ít theo mình sẽ kiểm
tra điều kiện thôi đó là nếu còn Nam thì
biến thành một Còn nếu không thì biến nữ
để ạ Thì đấy là bên lập trình
ở lại trại này có một bản bị xóa đúng
không xem lại nhé
Ừ nó Ok đúng không
ừ ừ
à à
a tiếp theo
có
hiện tượng với Tính không á ông đi đâu
đấy à
thế này ra
chị đánh giá khách hàng sinh tháng 1
đúng không có bạn đến câu này Tắt ở đây
ngon một vì nó có sao mà Nhưng mà thực
ra là các bạn nên chịu khó cha một tí
chứ không thể thấy mình rất Ánh Sao là
con nhờ nó sẽ đến cũng khó rồi các bạn
sẽ bỏ cuộc không
Ừ Đấy bây giờ các bạn hãy thể hiện mình
là người nằm trong hai mươi phần trăm
người còn lại đi đúng không trả lời Làm
được hết những cái bài này thì lương nó
có thể lên đến nghìn đâu đấy à
anh không anh vẫn ngồi thì loạn vào bình
luận ra chợ Xanh Không anh
à mình sẽ lấy tất cả khách hàng ra này
tôi tin sẽ rất sao còn cái nhà
sinh tháng 1 thì mình sẽ là que que cái
gì
ở đó có bạn có thể trả lời rồi nhé Bạn
trả lời Thấy thì mình sẽ chị mình sẽ chỉ
cách cho các bạn để trả lời mình sẽ có
là ăn
SQL Server được ạ
thì mình sẽ lấy hàm này
ở
đây là ép ra server đúng không Đó mằn
như này ăn như này Sao truyền ngày tháng
vào là có nhớ sẽ lấy được khám của nó
Ừ cái mình chạy thử câu này thì các bạn
sẽ rõ này Ừ thì chạy con này trước
ở đó lấy là tháng năm từ cái ngày tháng
năm sinh đúng không Đấy tức là sao anh
sẽ đây đẩy mắn từ ngày sinh
một ngày sinh lại cho nó bị bằng một pha
sẵn
ở những kiểu trả lời Làm gì giống thế
em có bạn chơi nhiều cách kiểm có bạn
thì dùng đến phát để mà kẻ ff cái này
sinh thành chỉ lấy ở đâu upon lấy phần
nó lấy phần của ngày ngày tháng năm ra
xong hỏi lấy mỗi màn hội cũng được cũng
không sao ăn này bạn chất là nó là như
thế mà có bạn thì dùng like
Ừ cũng được nhưng mà
ở cách này nó hơi bị
Hôm nay thì tao nó sẽ chậm hơn không
anh được có vài bạn trả lời được rồi Có
bạn chơi hẳn vết nêm rồi cho luôn tiếng
Anh hoàn luôn
Ừ cũng được đúng không
Ừ cái này các bạn mới thể hiện rõ việc
rồi các bạn hoàn toàn một bài Các bạn
hãy trả lời bằng nhiều cách mà đúng
không
a tiếp theo
ở đây thì sẽ là select sao com khách
hàng
a Where họ tên đúng không
trong danh sách tức là in này à
Ừ anh này
Minh và bởi vì đức là có có dấu nên anh
sẽ ghi cái này nhé
đất này
ở đó em giới tính bằng Nam thì anh ạ
anh hoặc mình có từ chỉ cần tất cả mình
cái hoặc này nó sẽ rất lớn mình sẽ là ảo
đây và nó sẽ ôm toàn bộ cả chạy như kiện
này và điều kiện này
30 like vừa rồi thì like rồi chắc là nó
không rơi được còn ngày sinh đâu Cái bạn
đấy dùng dùng kia mà khi mặc kiểu đấy
thì không nhận là nó hơi nông dân hơn tí
hạt nho
từ năm sinh lớn trước 2000 thì chuẩn đại
thì nó sẽ y xong rồi ngày sinh
nhỏ hơn 2.000 rồi ạ đúng không
anh như này
thế nhưng hồi trước chính mình chính
minh từ trả lời cái câu này ở trong bài
kiểm tra của mình và mình không biết cái
Hà Mi A nên mình sẽ trả lời theo cách
nông dân hơn nó sẽ như thế này
ông
thầy vẫn cho điểm bởi vì nó vẫn chạy
được
à à
À tớ thì rõ ràng là nhỏ hơn cái ngày này
thì rõ ràng là có phải là trước năm 2000
không đúng không nên thì nên thế này nó
vẫn đức tính gì
ở đây làm cách mà đúng không Không sai
gì cả
thế này các bạn trả lời câu này chị đã
tính em có sao đúng không
anh em cách Black thôi nhưng mà các bạn
không biết mày cái Hàn này của nó đúng
không cái Hàn này các bạn đã trao Google
chưa Mà trong lúc bài kiểm tra thì mình
có điều tra đâu đúng không ạ
em lấy ra khách hàng có tuổi lớn hơn 18
câu này khó hơn nếu mà các bạn muốn lấy
chính xác
cho các bạn một lấy Chính xác là qua qua
ngày sinh
Ừ rồi thì mới được là tuổi 18 thì công
nhận cái đấy nó sẽ khó hơn còn bây giờ
muốn làm Thế còn đơn giản nữa cậu là
I - năm sinh năm à năm nay ví dụ năm
hiện tại đúng không - năm sinh nó ra lớn
hơn 18 thì nó dễ hơn mình sẽ trả lời câu
đấy còn câu kia thì tra các để các bạn
trao Google trước đã nó
anh đi sẽ là Where
Gần ngày sinh là ngày đầu tiên là ở ngày
sinh nó xảy ra gì đã nó sẽ tuổi đúng
không Đây mình sẽ có
thì mình sẽ chỉ các bạn cách gì mà in ra
trước cái tuổi xem nó đúng hay sai đã á
tuổi này a app năm sinh đi năm sinh này
à
khi chọn xem qua đã nhé
ở đó đây
khi nó xảy ra hoặc sợi cáp nó sẽ chỉ lấy
50 đúng không Ok Thế bây giờ mình làm
thế nào để mình lấy ra được à
ở tuổi thì thường là lấy 5 năm nhận tải
- năm sinh thì ra tội đúng không có bạn
được trả lời được rồi thì khái niệm ở
đây các bạn tra nhất là các bạn cần phải
lấy Nam hiện tại thì nó ghét Bunny lại
biết một tiếng Anh là tốt
luôn hiện tại không
khi Apple server này cho cả thế
ở đây nó sẽ có hàm getdate mà Đây mình
chạy thử các bạn select như này có bạn
sẽ thấy
khi xảy ra năm 21 đúng không Thì mình
chỉ cần lấy số này - cái này là xong
giản thế thôi
em có bạn em trả lời khác mình Mình biết
nhưng mà thực ra cách nào nó cũng chạy
được làm bạn đúng không ạ
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn trả lời ngắn gọn kia
kìa à
em có bạn thì dùng hàm bếp ít nó chuẩn
hơn ngon
sao lại không trả
ở Hà Nội Lớn hơn đúng không cái này mới
trẻ trừ lớn hơn 18 này à
ở đó tất cả bạn này đều thỏa mãn về thử
tăng tuổi lên nhé 24 tuổi chắc ạ
ở đó chứ có một bạn thỏa mãn bạn 96 và
mãn thôi đúng không ừ ừ
tôi có bạn dùng đến đít là để mà - tháng
5 ngày thì nó rất là ổn và cái đít về có
thể lấy được ra chính sách tuổi nó sẽ
khái niệm đấy tít hết thế đi mèo đó gì
đít này tất cả nó sẽ nó sẽ
chửi chửi và cái này hay cực Hồi trước
mình được làm cái trò này để chia sẻ vui
các bạn học được trình đôi khi các bạn
cha và chia sẻ vui lại được các bạn mấy
cái vụ đấy sửa các bạn hoàn toàn thì -
ngày xinh xinh của chính mình với người
yêu của mình thôi Bấm vào rồi nó sẽ tính
ra lại là các bạn cách bao nhiêu ngày
bao nhiêu giờ bao nhiêu phút bao nhiêu
giây với ngày sinh người yêu đem khoe
được chợ
hoa Các bạn bấm ở đây xong rồi từ ngày
sinh cho đến trưa đây chán thì nó sẽ đi
ra được là các bạn đã
có bao nhiêu ngoài bao nhiêu năm thì sẽ
có bao nhiêu phút bao nhiêu giây
Em đã sống đã tồn tại
ai chả thế
em có một cái cái này thì không phải
biết mà ngon
Ừ chị Dân công nghệ thì mày cái vụ đấy
thôi
Chỉ có nhiêu đâu mà tính lắm thì em tính
này đến lúc có người yêu cũng được mà
à Em tính
anh có nhiều cái tính mà không khó tính
Mình đã độc thân bao nhiêu lâu để Ngã
em có khi đối với ông bị đó là tính bắt
đầu từ ngày sinh cho đến hiện tại
à à
ở tại sao để mấy cái loạn kiểu như thế
Béo Vậy cười ngã cười trong nỗi đau ạ ạ
Ừ ok 9:00 rồi nợ được xem đã dạy rằng
hạt mình cảm thấy mấy bạn kia bỏ mình đi
xem bóng đá mới thôi nhưng sao buồn mà à
à à
em lấy 3 khách hàng mới nhất thì thì bài
toán ở đây các bạn phải hiểu thế nào là
mới nhất lúc chưa
tin mới nhất ở đây tức lá là nếu mà dễ
hiểu nhất thì mới nhất ở đây ám chỉ ra
cái mã các bạn đấy lớn nhất được chưa
ừ ừ
cho
mình để mình sẽ chỉ các bạn Nếu thấy các
bạn chuẩn ra phải là sắp xếp Mã theo thứ
tự giảm dần sau đó thì lấy ba bạn và
chuẩn nhất
em sắp xếp Mã theo thứ tự giảm dần rồi
lấy ba bạn cần nhất thì sẽ là mới nhất
để khách ghé lấy
ở trong trong à Apple Server này thì nó
sẽ có cái à top 3 được hoặc top top gì
đấy nó sẽ đi đó sẽ lấy ba bạn lớn nhất
cái gì đấy
Ừ thế này là xong mà
Tik Tok em heo đi mid thì ở đây nó mặc
định tốt và nó có là lít rồi bạn chỉ cần
select top 3
ạ sau đó thì tên cột này ngon mã này còn
cái hả
anh như thế chạy thử nhé
à à
Ừ đúng vậy
Ừ đúng rồi nhớ đúng mà
đó thì sẽ lấy ra được ba bạn lớn nhất
đúng
Ờ Ờ nhưng mà thấy này thì các bạn sẽ
thấy là nó sẽ không ra được không ra
được toàn bộ danh sách đúng không Thì
mình sẽ là
ở đây mình sẽ là thuốc ba sao Đi xe mà
Anh hợp âm vì anh em
ở đó Nó xảy ra bà cái top 3 sao này
em mới nhất thì lấy từ dưới lên đúng
không
300 thức a không quan tâm với việc lấy
dưới lên nếu là các bạn muốn lấy từ lên
thì các bạn sẽ phải khái niệm về order
bye đặt sắp xếp nó lại nữa để mình xem
nhé thằng f-word Server này thì da mình
không động và nhiều lắm Em đi xem sẽ có
lấy treo
ô ô derby không
à à
Ừ hình như có
ở đây đấy cũng được à
ô ô đơ bay mã dsc này
ừ được được được à
à à
khi kết thúc ba này chỉ điều kiện của nó
sẽ lấy theo cột đầu tiên thôi để còn đầu
tiên để
để biết
anh
không tốt bà để giới hạn chứ đúng không
Tớ bà để giới hạn nhưng mà theo mình thì
nó lấy cho cột đầu tiên để kiểm tra xem
cuộc đời lớn nhất 20
à Còn order by này chắc cũng Ấn này có
đời bay để sắp xếp nó theo thứ tự giảm
dần thì nó sẽ lấy luôn đấy thằng mới
nhất đến trước đúng không ạ
khi EC axit em như thế định luật nên
mình sẽ lấy những thằng cũng ngất lên
trước là như này và tự nhiên bây giờ
mình đang có 3 theme viên ba khách hàng
thế như là sự đổi hình hay nhưng ai trở
lại thì bạn sẽ thấy da thì nó sẽ chị 222
người cũ nhất đúng không
Thế C mới là mới nhất này chưa
Anh đang trả lời mày có sao này ra là có
thể nhiều bạn sẽ hơi khó hiểu một tí thì
nên là mình sẽ trả lời nhanh cho bạn nào
có thắc mắc thôi đúng không ạ
em lấy ra bạn khách hàng có tên chứa tê
Ở đây có anh Tuấn luôn đúng không Chắc
là cần tên có chứa chữ T thì cô ấy thật
ra nhiều bạn nếu mà bạn học thôi thì bạn
thường đi bạn cũng quá quen câu này cũng
là dễ không còn lại khó như bạn chưa
biết thì có ai sẽ thương người khó thì
cách để mã các bạn tra tên chứa một cái
từ gì đó thì sẽ que họ tên này like này
phần trăm phần trăm của tên Nga đúng
không
Ừ tôi có bạn trai luôn rồi đấy Tại sao
nhưng mà bây giờ mình bờ Để mình hỏi
những cái bạn Mà học cái này rồi nhé Xem
các bạn có thực sự là khó hiểu cái ông
nhá
ạ Bây giờ mình chạy cái này Đầu tiên
trước đã các bạn hãy ra anh Tuấn đúng
không em chưa Bên mình đổi tên thành tên
không biết hoa thì nó có anh Tuấn không
ạ Các bạn trả lời rồi đi không không
chơi cho chạy thử cốc sau đó trả lời rồi
nhé Ừ đấy Quán chạy thử à các bạn thử
đoán xem cái này có cho anh Tuấn không
ở đâu mà tôi tưởng có nghề ông học học
trước xem video này lắm rồi bây giờ toàn
những bạn mới
em toàn những lời ông học rồi rồi nằm
vùng ở đây tôi biết mà đi
đã có người trả lời có người không mà
trong hợp đồng đều đúng không nó chạy
thử thì biết đúng
anh có được chưa anh có tiếp theo nhé
Bây giờ mình sẽ thử đổi nó là chứ
ô chữ
em chửi ngày theo các bạn nó sẽ ra ai
không
Ừ đúng rồi cây xăng cities Được hỗ trợ
Nội
Em hãy Thế chứng tỏ nhiều bông vừa rồi
mang tiếng Hấp rồi nhưng cũng chưa biết
về khái niệm khái niệm đấy đúng không
tiếp theo Lần này thì nó khói không
anh không ạ Ok chạy thử thì biết đúng
không Không đúng không Bởi vì sao Bởi vì
đây có dấu đúng không em chưa
ở đây mình đổi nó thì chị An thì có dao
à à
em không có không có không
khi chạy thử thì lại biết đúng không
chị sẽ thử
anh không nữa
Vì sao chưa Mày nó không ra
Nghe nhạc mới thêm n đằng trước thì nó
có ra không
Ừ đấy mì ông học rồi nhưng mấy ông có
thực sự là đi sâu vào như thế nào không
Nó nói ra anh Tuấn có ở không phải ra
bạn anh bạn anh thì kệ đi cho anh Tuấn
cơ chạy cái này có anh Tuấn không
Ê mày có không có không
Ai bảo không ra đúng không
Ừ đúng nó không ra
Ừ nhưng mà tại sao tự nhiên mình mình
lại hỏi câu này ở đây rõ ràng các bạn
hãy hiển nhiên là trong Trực Tuấn đây
mình mình cho bạn sẽ lại nhé
ở trong chữ Tuấn thì thì rõ ràng có chữa
chẳng qua nó nó có thêm có dấu đúng
không
A N O thì tôi nhờ Chắc là nó ra rồi Cái
này không nói cái này hơi cái này trước
là nó ra rồi đúng không Nhưng ý mình ở
đây Đấy Đó là các bạn mà chạy thử cái
này trên bên mái queo trên máy ảo
thì em các bạn chạy các lệnh này được
chưa nó sẽ ra cả bạn tên là Tuấn
anh
nói điện mà không còn may vì không có cả
đời luôn
Ừ Để mai hỏi thì kệ họ tên của nó nó lưu
lại là Kiểu ni cô sẵn rồi và khi mà nó
dùng like khi dùng lại thì nó sẽ không
phân biệt luôn cậu như cốc cả không nhi
cốt thành ra lạc
Ừ thế thì nên ở trong trường hợp mà bên
mái queo mà chạy lệnh này thì nó xảy ra
được cả bạn Tuấn các bạn anh chưa nó
không phân biệt hoa thường và không cả
Unicode còn trong Access server vừa rồi
bạn có thấy đó là chim like thì nó chị
không phân biệt hoa thường thôi còn
unicoat thì vẫn phải thêm nơ và vẫn phải
ghi đầy đủ có xấu được chưa các bạn cha
không để vụ này Nhưng mà mình làm bên
bên tay thì mình có đi qua mình cái vụ
này đó là vì sau mình dạy các bạn về máy
của em mà Đúng không các bạn sẽ cần phải
biết la lá biết kiến thức bên làm tí đó
Khi mà like này thì bạn chất là nó sẽ So
sánh thế nào nữa tương tự Vì như mình
nhớ không làm tại bình thường mở máy
quét Xin chào mình đề cập vào các bạn ấy
quên mai có một tí các bạn đỡ bỡ ngỡ Ý
mình bảo mình sẽ dậy ạ
t-sql mà mình không dậy Về hẳn chuyên về
FTP server mà mình sẽ có tí nhắc đến máy
của em nhé á
em có database database của mình học thì
phải
ở tạm tắt n70 tin đi
Có ai có quản lý sinh viên đấy mình có
sinh viên này
anh có lòng Nam nghe đúng không bị đổi
tên bạn Tuấn trả lại cũng chưa mình có
bạn Tuấn bây giờ sự là mình à xe Max II
Vì sao Phones sinh viên đúng không Where
tên bằng
Anh Tuấn
Theo các bạn cái này chạy có ra bạn Tuấn
à à
à à ở lại cái lệnh này sẽ có ra sinh
viên tên là Tuấn 20
em hỏi thử thôi rõ nhỉ
Sau
đó các bạn sẽ thấy là bên bên mái khoe
Eo nó khác với cả SQL Server
là cái việc phân biệt có dấu của nó nó
khác hoàn toàn đúng không thấy rõ ràng
là mình không cần dùng like mình dùng
bằng luôn đúng không so sánh nó vẫn ra
cái này là cái
Ê thằng thằng Apple máy quen mà không
chặt chẽ bằng thằng FTP server và cái
này hồi trước đã từng sinh mình cái mô
Ừ được rồi bạn nhớ nhớ cái câu mình vừa
nói thỉnh thoảng mình nói một câu gì đói
này các bạn nên nhiều nó nghe máy của em
nó không phân biệt unikode đúng không ừ
ừ
Ừ đúng rồi có bạn Vừa bảo bây giờ mới
biết vụ này đúng không đúng hôm trước
cái này nó xinh mình cái bất này mình
mới biết cái vụ này like này thì không
phân biệt hóa thường còn về nhưng mà còn
về có dấu thì thì like này nó không ảnh
hưởng gì cả mà do chính cái thằng hệ cái
thằng hệ quản trị cái thằng cơ sở liệu
thẳng xwork2 là thằng Mai với nó mấy
thằng Quyết Định xem là unicol nó nó so
sánh bằng 20
A gọi Hôm nay dạy hơi bị quá do mình tí
nhưng sẽ cho các bạn
Ừ thôi mình sẽ trả nốt cái vụ này để
nhắc về cái vụ trách chung các thứ thứ
để các bạn biết
đây mình thay đổi bạn đó là enter enter
p.bồ được chưa Chị sẽ khái niệm enter
thay bộ
Ừ để mà thay đổi cấu trúc dữ liệu của
bạn các bạn sẽ được dùng enter
à mà
Ý mình bảo là đốt Chị ở có sẽ có buổi
dài hơn nửa tiếng mà à và mình chỉ nhập
được ngày sinh bé hơn ngày Hiện tại thì
sẽ là
cho mình mình sẽ là kiểu enter p.bồ rồi
mình thay đổi dữ liệu thì đây là sự mình
à thay đổi dữ liệu của cột ngon enter
table Hồi nãy
con Luyện ạ con luôn là cột lại sau
ashworth
chào các bạn cha như này rồi các bạn sẽ
nên lên thường hay lên tra w3school chưa
các bạn xem ví dụ là đây nó sẽ khái niệm
là thêm một cột mới này hay là xóa cột
cũ đi này thay đổi cấu trúc của cột đây
cái thử minh cần quan tâm Đấy mình sẽ
cần đổi cả cấu trúc của cột thì KFC
server Mình đã học thì nó sẽ đã enter có
lùm xong rồi tên cột 1 tên kiểu dữ liệu
sau đó rất nhiều cái nữa bây giờ xử là
mình không muốn rút cái bảng này đi
giống như mọi sim eload Còn bây giờ mình
chỉ muốn đổi cột Thôi thì mình sẽ là An
tơ p.bồ sau đó thì enter có lum tự nhiên
mình phải Thị Nghi đầy đủ là thấy bổ cho
sinh viên này sợ enter luôn rồi mình đi
tiếp
mà có lung nào ta sử bây giờ mình muốn
đổi cột ngày sinh đúng không
biến đổi cột ngày sinh
các kiểu dữ liệu của nó mình vẫn sẽ giữ
nguyên mà mình chỉ nói thêm về vụ là
mình kiểm tra sao cho
anh không được nhập ngày sinh bé hơn
ngày Hiện tại thì mình vừa dùng từ kiểm
tra và chính em từ trách kiểm tra chặt
chẽ dữ liệu mình nhập vào cái chưa
xe khách Hà ở Xin lỗi Xin lỗi mình sẽ bị
ngáo Chứ đi sang bên kia là sinh viên
karaoke đó
Sau đó mình sẽ kiểm tra như thế này và
kiểm tra cái này mình sẽ kiểm tra cái gì
kiểm tra ngày sinh không không bé hơn
này tại Đúng không ngày tại mình lễ đâu
mình lấy từ chính trên này này cái Hà
ghét ghét vừa nãy mình copy đây này nói
chuyện này hiện tại chưa và mình chỉ cần
là cái ngày sinh khi mình truyền vào ấy
thì nó là như thế này mình sẽ là
nhớ ngày sinh
nhớ
ngày sinh này
lớn hơn ngày hiện tại thế là xong rồi
Ừ ok
Ừ anh nhong nhong nhong em xin lỗi
support bé hơn mình nhá quá cần nhầm bé
hơn lớn hơn nữa đấy à
nhớ ngày sinh bé hơn ngày hiện tại ok
đấy Đúng rồi chạy
phụ trách Nội à
Anh Bình nhớ là có trách cả trong nghe
kìa server mỉ ạ
ở ngõ visa
ừ ừ
Ừ hai cái này phải
khi khai báo riêng à đâu
em hết thương nhớ thương nhớ à
à à
cách
hạn cái này đi tạo một cái con chết Ok
thử này
chứ không phải lỗi Tại sao nhỉ
300 tạo bảo bình thường vẫn cho check mà
It is trách nhiệm AAA Ok Ok Xin lỗi Xin
lỗi
ở cây Attack tiếng đổi rồi
ở đó đó thực ra là cái này không làm một
cái nhầm lẫn của mình và Chắc là bây giờ
các bạn cũng nhớ luôn đó là cái này
không phải là thay đổi của cột mà cái
check là check này nó không dính đến cái
cột nào cả nó độc lập với cột nên là
mình không cần phải enter có luôn như
thế này đúng không xin lỗi xin lỗi đó là
áp trách như này là xong chưa em Đúng
rồi chạy thử này Ok thành công rồi đúng
không đó
ý nghĩa nó độc lập với cột đúng không
Tại sao mình phải dùng từ độc lập với
cột bởi vì hoàn toàn các bạn trong cái
chết này các bạn hãy kiểm tra nhiều yếu
tố và xử là thậm chí có thêm một câu nữa
Chẳng ạ là
anh
chỉ nhập được giới tính
nam với bạn tên
Long nhận ra xu thế là xử thế thì mình
sẽ hoàn toàn an enter p.bồ được như này
act một lần nữa và lần này mình sẽ lại
là
giới tính bằng một ngon
các
em à
Anh tên bằng lắm sẽ nặn thế
Mở bài kiểu nhà thì bắt buộc giới tính
phải bằng một họ tên bằng Long Nhưng mà
nếu mà trong chừng có tên là tên tên là
người khác thì đương nhiên là mình không
cần kiểm tra này đúng không Thì mình sẽ
là
mình sẽ hoàn toàn cho cái này phải trong
mặt tròn
ở Mỹ Tho
Anh tên khác Long
trong chuỗi đúng
khi họ tên nhà nói họ tên họ tên nhé
Ừ cái này tức là sao nghĩa là
vì vậy tệ Bạn tới Long thì mình sẽ kiểm
tra Bác vừa giới tính bằng 1 còn mới Bạn
tên khác lắm đúng không
Ừ thì mình hoàn toàn không kiểm tra gì
cả chưa
anh chạy nãy ok rồi bây giờ sự mình sẽ
thử Insert into khách hàng
mình sẽ truyền họ tên
copy mình có video nhanh nhé
ở đây tên 5 này chúng không giới tính mà
không đi chẳng hạn đổi đây mỗi tí nữa
không chạy này đó các bạn sẽ thấy báo
lỗi liên quan đến mua cái trách nào đó ở
đây nó bảo liên quan đến cái check đó
cũng chưa đấy
thì nó sẽ kiểm tra hộ các bạn về cái vụ
vụ này đấy đấy tác dụng của czech và đấy
tác dụng của cái mà hôm nay mình dậy đó
là cái ràng buộc với dữ liệu là
đã ràng buộc bắt buộc phải nhập vào đúng
các thứ thứ Ngoài ra còn thêm một cái
nữa nó nhanh này cho hết bộ ông cũng đảo
xa với buổi rồi thì sẽ nói nhanh ở đây
về cái vụ iPhone iPhone là khi mà các
bạn không truyền giá trị và học thì nó
sẽ cho một giá trị mặc định nào đó ra xử
là các bạn thấy à
Ừ cái ta cũng tiện này giờ sự là các bạn
thấy à
Anh làm sao biết được có những chất nào
thì đây để từ khóa tra ví dụ Maxwell
ghét disk ejector mã
đại lý tao check contact đáy in SQL
Server database này đó
Ồ thông báo lỗi thì các bạn phải phải
mắt phải kiểm tra xem à lỗi lỗi do đâu
đúng không Đương nhiên là với cái này
thì các bạn sẽ ra rất khó để biết được
lỗi do cái gì Đúng chưa Bởi vì tên của
cái con check này cái con trên là đúng
không Nó đang làm các bạn mông lung đây
do mà có bạn hỏi mình tại sao lại nên
đặt tên cho cái cái con trên phải mất
công và tên làm gì đúng không ạ bây giờ
sự là mình tạo chắc là mình phải rút bạn
đi Nếu không thì phải xóa check nó sẽ
xóa check cũng phải xóa khớp với cái tên
chết không anh ra check em ạ Đấy à
Ở mái dốc trách nhân
Ừ chắc à phải gõ đúng cái tên này thì
mới đốt được này
đấy bạn khách hàng
Ừ ok rồi này bao lần này khi mà app
check này mình sẽ đặt tên cho nó là con
chết như này sao kiếm được tên là giúp
là
Anh check
thế giới tính
kèm tên Long hạ là tên sao cho nó
dễ hình dung đúng không
Ừ rồi anh check lại phân nữa này
đã sôi lần này mình shop này
ở đó thì các bạn sẽ thấy nó lỗi là liên
quan đến cái tre có cái tên như nay thì
các bạn nhìn cái biết ngay là ok Nó vi
phạm vào một cái check nào đấy học chữ
hỏi cái tên là mông lung được như vừa
nãy như thế này một con số do như thế
này các bạn không thể biết trách đấy nó
yêu cầu cái gì cũng ngon đấy do các bạn
phải đặt tên cho cái con trên còn không
nên mặc định nó sẽ tự động điền các bạn
có số gì Hỏi như này chưa
Cái này tương tự giống như là khi các
bạn Nhập giá trị Gọi cho cụt à
ở cột ví dụ là cột bit này nha các bạn
Nhập sai bây giờ sửa của giới tính đúng
không các bạn Nhật là hẳn 100 hay là ăn
chuối đúng á đôi chuỗi hành ABCD em ạ
thì nó sẽ báo các bạn cần lỗi
Ừ đấy nhưng mà lỗi này thì lỗi này lỗi
có sẵn của Thắng thằng e kia server nó
sẽ như bị lỗi nó không phải là chết
không phải là cái mà mình đã tạo ở đây
đúng không Mà nó sẽ bảo lỗi một cách cụ
thể hơn là kiểu không được khai báo kiểu
dữ liệu kiểu gì cũng sẽ cụ thể hơn chưa
Con Gà bây giờ cũng lên hàng gần hai
tiếng thôi cha tặng xem còn cái gì ông
nha
ừ ừ
à à
anh
kể chắc à bây giờ tạm kết thúc nó nghỉ
có bạn còn sáo diều
ở đài cách ngon ơ à Cậu trả lời câu hỏi
của hôm nay chắc là để mọi hôm sau mình
có thời gian mình trả lời nhé cả câu
chuyện về
tâm sự nơi thực tập nữa đúng không
em chưa học bài 10 ra các bạn nãy giờ
còn đang hơi bị nhầm thì ra nãy giờ đã
học bài mới rồi đấy iPhone lại lại quên
nhắc về vụ default đúng không
anh nói nhanh về vụ level Thôi để cho nó
ngắn lắm thì cô các bạn chị để khô Các
bạn đúng là phải sửa trên
phải sửa can thiệp enter vào trong bảng
thật và sửa enter có lung Vì sẽ truyền
đạt sự mình cho giới tính giới tính vì
để vô rồi tính À cái rẻ nhất ở trong
đồng này thì sẽ defoe giới tính là
có một chàng lặn như này Đương nhiên
mình phải có kiểu dữ liệu ngay Ok mày
chạy đấy
Ừ hè lại bảo lỗi
Em mở cái này cũng say nhé
hbp bao lâu
thử xem
khi sex trong bài Thử chức xét à ok ok
à à
ừ ừ
ở đây đấy
à à
Ừ
đúng rồi nhỉ
anh vẫy trưởng cần phải ác còn chết nữa
anh
không không cần không cần lấy thêm cái
đoạn mà này ý nghĩa thế
Em chỉ cần Thể loại này thôi I ở
đây phẩm Một này Paul suy tính xem thử
nhé
ở Pháp luật
trong trường hợp thêm đều phải đúng là
phải thêm chữ này sao rồi chị sẽ đặt tên
nó là giới tính mặc định đi
ở đó rồi bây giờ sự mình Insert lại phát
nữa Nhà mình không có một giới tính thì
các bạn sẽ thấy giới tính nó sẽ mặc định
là một thì thôi
khi chọn đồ đúng không
bình thường là thường là các bạn ạ
ở tại sao vừa rồi mình bị bỡ ngỡ như thế
Ừ lần này bị bị bị bỡ ngỡ thật bởi vì
mình không động vào bên em cho server
nhiều mình Mình chuyên bán máy queo hơn
nhưng mà các bạn thấy là việc mình tra
Google để mà ra được cái kết quả đấy sẽ
ra bản chất lập trình viên nó cũng thế
mà mình đang thể hiện rõ các bạn vì khi
lập trình viên thì cách đi bốc nó như
thế nào đúng không là bị treo Google
thôi đúng không sao Mày copy code về so
với hãy hi vọng nó sẽ chạy đúng không
Đấy nó không Không đến nỗi là kiểu đội
đối các bạn có thể à thầy thầy không
được phép sai sót hay là các thứ đến nhà
mình có chuẩn bị bài trước nhé
thế nhưng nhưng mà có những cái gì đôi
nhà mình không thể nghĩ mọi trường hợp
được nghe thỉnh thoảng cũng sẽ phải
Google Nhưng mà Cái quan trọng là mình
sẽ chẳng giấu giếm các bạn về cái việc
đấy và
ạ Mình chẳng ngại thì việc đấy vì lập
trình viên nặng sẽ Google thôi gì chưa
cho nên là không không Mình thấy không
có gì ngại ở đây cả các bạn cười cũng
được mình chẳng ngại thì ra đi
Ừ đúng rồi Các bạn nên tạo iPhone trực
thực tế thì ra là rất ít khi mà các bạn
tạo check nó cả để sau sau phải phải
enter nhé Thực ra các bạn ngay từ lúc
Red Label là các bạn phải có những cái
đấy rồi chuẩn là như thế em
Ừ cái vụ về tâm sự về
Ẩm Thực tập viết chữ k mình thấy nó đã
bị đúng video lên hẳn ái tiếng thôi nên
là mình nghĩ là chắc là để buổi sau vậy
nhá mình tặng thất các bạn buổi sau đi
bây giờ là mình như mình thông báo là
chắc là
Ừ
cái á một tuần sẽ là ba buổi nên là bây
giờ sẽ có thêm nhiều thời gian để gặp
các bạn hơn các bạn càng nóng lòng chứ
lại càng tốt đúng không nghe có cái gì
đó để bụi sau trả lời nhé với sau mình
cũng sẽ mình còn nói qua đấy với sau
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về khoa ngoại khoa
ngoại nha chứ không phải là khóa phụ đâu
mẹ các bạn thế kỷ đặt trước qua tài liệu
của mình cũng kia đọc trên mạng vân vân
để bạn hiểu qua tại sao mình không gọi
nó khóa phụ mà Tại nó lại khó ngoại khóa
ngoại tức là nào Vân Vân Nga đi
Xin chào các bạn thôi Nghe chưa bài tập
các bạn cố đợi tầm lượt nửa tiếng nữa sẽ
có bài tập trên cái link Teka bồ các thử
nhé Ok và mình sẽ ở mình sẽ đăng ký khóa
biểu mới
Ừ Ok chào các bạn
à à
à Mà buổi và 357 nhé ba buổi tối 357
ừ ừ